[Music]
Matthew Maddie yep Dr Molen WG not a
doctor at all in my heart of hearts
you're always a doctor I think in
Argentina I got an honorary degree
actually in that in that country I'm I'm
so JY Argentina I haven't been back in
100 years but we're not here to talk
about my aspirations and dreams although
maybe yeah I hope to hear some well
we'll we'll Dive In and Out Bob and
weave for people who don't have context
on the Argentine doctor
M could you give people just a snapshot
ah sure so yeah Matt Mullen wig domain
M.T which is pretty
Funt sometimes born and raised in
Houston Texas few hours from here in
Austin and at the age of 19 I co-founded
open source software called
WordPress which is a blogging content
management system fast forward 20 years
it's been 20 years now and runs over a
third of all websites in the world a few
years after that I co-founded or founded
a company called automatic which is kind
of like the for-profit side of
commercializing things around WordPress
automattic M2 yes it's it's like any
etical founder I snuck my name into the
company
and we started with just sort of aism
anti-spam and wordpress.com kind of easy
ways to get going with WordPress but
since have expanded to e-commerce with W
Commerce one I'll talk about with with
messaging like we've done a number over
like 25 Acquisitions so we're trying to
be like a digital Burkshire hathway like
a buyer of First Resort for amazing
things on internet pretty much
everything we do is open source or open
web so oh we bought Tumblr so we're
running Tumblr for the last few years
basically trying to yeah I would like
future Generations to grow up with a web
that is more open more free gives more
Liberty and so open source is really my
life's work even above WordPress and
anything else and yeah I hope to work on
it the rest of my life you are one of
the rare examples and I'm so envious of
this particular sort of mental state of
focus that you have which is this
Clarity on what you want to do something
you could do for the rest of your life
with with that degree of certainty it's
something that's
always struck me as rare and maybe not
as a consequence of being rare but
precious in a sense so anyway I'm happy
for you like it's it's it's I don't run
across that much from a professional
perspective's like I want to do this for
the rest of my life I think it's because
the open source freedom and liberty
somewhat abstract so there could be lots
of things under that but I just
mentioned probably too many things some
people will call me very unfocused but
you have that too we talked about on the
last podcast around like teaching
learning education like lifelong that's
the rest of your life yeah and so I
think if you can find those principles
you can keep them and then the job might
change other things might change I'm
lucky to work at the same job because
I'm probably unemployable anywhere else
at this point but it's been a lot of fun
oh automatic now over 1,00 people and 97
countries we were fully remote and
distributed since 2005 so we've been
kind of early on a few of those Trends
open source distributed etc for people
and I know we've talked about this
before and you've certainly talked about
it in other places but we're going to
get into a lot of new territory before
we do that though open source just for
people who may not have familiarity with
that term what does that mean yeah so
normally when you sign up for software
you click through that license you know
that no one ever reads ours actually has
Easter eggs in it just to see if anyone
will find them most of those licenses
are about all the rights you don't have
mhm you know sometimes you're not even
allowed to look at the thing and see how
it works there's a whole right to repair
movement right now where you can buy
things that you're not even allowed to
repair yourself open source is the
opposite it's all about almost like a
Bill of Rights for you as the user so
you word press belongs just as much to
Tim Ferris as it does to me which is
kind of amazing there's rights and
freedoms you have to use it for any
purpose to modify it to see how it works
all these sorts of things that no one
can take away from you even myself as a
co-founder or even if all the other
developers got together we all agreed to
become evil we couldn't take it away
from you that Bill of Rights those inali
rights is is the core of Open Source and
there's lots of examples so like
Wikipedia is open source applied to an
encyclopedia right it used to be really
bad in car encyclopedia britanica were
way better but then over time lots of
people working together made it better
and better and why did they work on it
for free for fun and also because it
belongs to them MH so you know WordPress
has many thousands maybe probably tens
of thousands of contributors to this
point why do they do that it's not
because I'm you know is it Tom Sawyer
painting the fence or is it the other
guy uh
you know I need more caffeine to be on
my literary references yeah but you know
the wow we should both know that wow I'm
embarrassed for both of us Tom Sawyer
and it'll be the first thing in the
comments Huckleberry F Huckleberry F
yeah mhm it's because it actually
belongs to people so sometimes people
come in and just fix one bug that's
annoying them or sometimes you know you
have the pride of knowing that Cod you
wrote is running on a third of all
websites in the world which is actually
like a real thrill was like an engineer
developer and that's just a lot of fun
so and it's openly collaborative in that
way not to State the obvious but it's a
contrast to actually this news item I
saw in news is probably giving it a
little bit too much gravitas but I read
this story which seemed credible based
on the source I'm not going to give too
much but that this engineer joins a
startup actually well and fixes one or
two bugs or develops a feature that he
wanted in the product and then put ince
and that was two weeks later yeah I love
that story um because I know so many
like on the Spectrum Engineers that
would totally do that it's like a
beautiful hat right for like I just got
to get this fixed they won't there's
actually companies I would do that one
thing I have considered is like secret
shopping like seeing if I could get
hired by my own company under a fake
Identity or yeah just something like
that kind of fun so why would you do
that
oh one to experience the hiring process
which is difficult for me to debug
except by secondhand
accounts two to see if I you know how my
code still is is do companies provide
mystery shopper like services for hiring
processes or no because mystery shoppers
right this would be the equivalent to
say retail yeah yeah where there are
companies you can hire they send people
into stores to experience the touch
points and the flow or lack of flow and
then to report back so you can improve
your operations and you have that for
security right you can hire people to
red team and try to exploit or defeat
your security and then you get a report
back and you can improve things does
that exist for something like a hiring
process it probably does but I'm a big
believer and especially Executives going
in doing the work themselves engaging
with the customers doing customer
support trying out the product building
a you know website whatever it is that
your thing is I think that's so key you
know I might be making this up but it's
something along the lines of 2 weeks of
Frontline service even if it's a CFO or
someone who's and actually I'm going to
be doing so every no matter the job
you're hired for it automatic you start
with two weeks of support and then every
single person rotates back in one week
per year and I'm running out a year so
I'm actually squeezing mine in at the
very end here so if you go to
wordpress.com support in the next two
weeks you might get me but uh yeah I
talked to Executive at Salesforce I was
really impressed they were saying they
spend 50% of their time with customers
this was a top executive running an
organization of thousands of people I
was like wow that's that's inspiring to
me like that's I'm probably I'm probably
25 or 30% right now so it really made me
think like am I spending enough time
customers and and also like we might
have some Executives that are spending
closer to 0% time so like how do we make
this like a cultural thing throughout
the company so you're an enthusiastic
fell part of why part of why I like
spending time with you Good Vibes lots
of smiles lots of laughs and you also
find a lot of things that are
interesting out at the edges and you're
you're an Immaculate Packer of bags also
so for those who do not know what's in
my bag every year gives the latest and
greatest of Matt's Tech gadgetry and
assorted dads and do hickeys that that
he's traveling with as a road warrior
who travels fear to say most of the time
right your schedule we're going to we're
going to get to my first planned
question in a second I I recall maybe it
was 5 months ago 6 months ago who knows
you you sent me something along the
lines of just in case we can overlap
here's where I'll be in the next year
and it was one of the most absurd it was
like a Rolling
Stones
tour are you continuing to do that in
terms of travel for the next year yeah
currently mm so yeah why do I go into it
well it's a global Community mhm so one
have a global company and a global
community so our hack for automatic
because we're aart most of the year is
the teams get together a couple times a
year so if you're an individual
contributor you might travel two three
times a year but as CEO this means that
every week there's like a couple of
meetups happening MH and so if I and I
try to hit the the bigger ones you know
sometimes the small ones too but mostly
the the really big ones where there's a
couple hundred people there but that's
happening at least once a month then for
WordPress there's like three major work
camps per year that have thousands of
people so there's there's all these
different I just a state of the word in
Madrid so you just take those you're
you're traveling a week out of the month
already then you got add in some
fun and um you're not going to die with
fun deficiency you how to have
fun yeah it really adds up but I have it
does take more of a toll than it used to
I got to be totally honest there was
years I did like well over 400,000 miles
and looking back I was like you know I
don't know if maybe I still have some of
the energy or maybe I'm getting more
radiation in the plane I don't know
maybe I'm just getting older it does
happen to people 40 in a few weeks I
know thank God so no more of this 30
under 30 40 under 40 nonsense you've
accumulated 700 lifetimes worth of those
so you mentioned Gatherings and the
first cone that we're going to weave
around on this slom of a conversation is
things that are exciting you things
you're excited about five or more and I
enjoy this format it's very simple I
haven't done it much and it's a shame
because I always have a good time doing
it where would you like to start I
mentioned messaging mhm so if you look
at automatics history it's like 2005
logging CMS 2016 Commerce L Commerce
it's grown to over 30 billion of sales
or gmv and we entered our third major
area this year which was messaging mhm
so we acquired this company called text
you might remember these sorts of
programs but you know we all have 20
different messaging apps text currently
takes 10 of them it will take more in
the future so signal WhatsApp you know
telegram Facebook Messenger Instagram
messenger Twitter DMS all these sorts of
things some of which have terrible
interfaces it brings them in the one
power user app right now desktop only
because it's all Ultra secure so it
doesn't break any encryption or run
anything in the cloud it's all on your
device which is I think very very
important like Engineers you have like a
code of ethics think we need to build
things extra secure now and yeah brings
them all together it's really nice I
often like acquire apps or invest in
things to make up for my own
deficiencies so like investing calm in
like 2012 or whatever it was cuz I felt
like I need to meditate uh so I'm was so
behind on messages I'm like okay we got
to buy this company and yeah and make it
available it's like a much more
expensive version of the guy who gets
hired and fixes the bugs and then leaves
buying buying buying companies small
team really really exciting and it's
yeah I don't know I'd love for you to
try it actually my team is using it and
they that's right actually told me about
this even before I had heard about it
myself so some some credit there so the
team team is loving it I have used it
and it is a great product where can
people find it or learn more about it
text.com
texts.com
texts.com all right text.com and if you
go on desktop and it's paid product
right now mhm so 15 bucks a month five
bucks a month if you're a student or
pretend to be a student
and uh but we're also going to explore
some different things mobile app is
coming out next uh year in the early
part and we're going to explore some
different pricing as well maybe making
it free for one or two networks paid for
more that's some very exciting stuff
there all right so I want to ask you a
strategy question to the extent that you
can discuss it so you were kind enough
to well spend a lot of time with me just
as a friend overall which I really
appreciate love spending time with you
and also just because disclosures are
important I am available at your Beck
call
advisor with automaticly days from the
early days and I am fascinated by not
just how you operate in the world but
how you think about the world right
because that's a prerequisite for making
a lot of not necessarily contrarian
because you can be a a different form of
sheep as a contrarian to by just doing
the opposite of what everyone else does
that's easy but picking and choosing
where you're going to be unorthodox or
approach things obliquely is more
challenging so the question and I'm
going to set the table with some some
other examples but the question is how
you choose what you're going to get into
in terms of areas products Etc right
because there's diversification there's
lack of focus there's Synergy these
words we can throw around I would love
to know how you think about for instance
or thought about getting into Commerce
right which I think is a more obvious
leap in my mind than say messaging mhm
and what I've observed is saying the
media landscape well the media landscape
and the social media platform Landscapes
have collided in such a major way in say
the last 5 to 10 years where you have
Amazon Studios you've got Netflix you've
got messaging and then video and so on
that are seemingly all being pursued on
some level by a lot of these large
Platforms in the form say WhatsApp or
whatever it might be so how do you
choose what to engage in next and you
said some people might say I'm unfocused
I don't consider you unfocused but there
are sometimes sort of hidden or unspoken
rationals or Logics behind so how do you
how do you think about what you're going
to do next I do think about it for a
long time M so we've been thinking about
messaging and actually making
investments in the space
for yeah four or five years mhm think a
lot about environment and incentives so
one thing you know the reason there used
to be these multi messaging apps 15
years ago and they all stopped working
was the networks all block
them and there is a political
environment now which I think is more
conducive to being more customer and
user Centric like this is our data right
this is our messages it's all secure
it's not breaking security or anything
so why shouldn't we be able to run this
now when you could you give an example
of a network
blocking these kind of multi message
tools in the past yeah it happened last
week there was another one called beeper
um that supported iMessage and apple
decided to just shut it down they broke
it all and people had actually charge
its users they had to refund everyone
like yeah there's also more subtle
things they could do like they could
just subtly
degrade if they make it so your messages
don't go through 5% of the time it's not
blocking you sure right but you're going
to stop using it it's like throttling
your hotel speed on Wi-Fi so you upgrade
to the premium you're like okay all
right they don't need to block you which
might draw attention they can just make
a little more painful and it doesn't
take a lot of friction for people to
move away especially in messaging so the
regulatory framework both with the EU
doing a lot of sometimes misguided but
also sometimes really smart they have a
an act coming in called the dma that
requires some interop between messaging
services you know we'll talk about USBC
which I'm very excited about that thank
you EU for forcing Apple to finally drop
lightning and give us USBC and then in
the US I think there is bipartisan this
I actually don't agree with but it is a
reality like some extra scrutiny on big
Tech mhm and so I think it's actually
good for them again what are their
incentives I think it's actually really
good for them to show that they're open
right now so again I don't want to fight
these folks they've got more money than
most
countries they could squash us like a
bug if they really really wanted to but
we're always doing things open source
user Centric and so like it's it'd be a
bad look for them to try to squash if
you have the people on your side I feel
like that's what truly matters in long
term and people are what short-term you
know lobbying Etc but like longterm in
the US Dem functioning democracy
politics is accountable to its people
and so so if we come back to what you
said and the whole point of this format
is scaffolding and then we can deviate
so we're deviating right now people may
have noticed talking about a let's just
say a NextGen or digital Berkshire
hathway right so burshire hathway could
have well originally textiles but they
could have insurance then they could
have something that is CH chocolates
right Seas candies things that are
completely
unrelated on a face value business level
right they're not integrated in the way
that a a CMS or having a gajillion blogs
and websites running on your platform
would combine very easily with
woocommerce right so th those two pair
very nicely are you thinking about say
in the case of text.com that that is a
standalone in the same way that some of
these Berkshire Pathways might be a
standalone how do you think about
building and acquiring in that way are
they are they standal loans how much do
they need to help each other or not in
the case of of Berkshire right like the
the insurance premiums and so on as I
understand it provide a huge bolus of
cash for all sorts of other purposes
right so sort of the the capital can be
utilized uh across the family in a sense
yeah how how do you do you think about
because there's so many different ways
you could rank order the priorities when
looking at potential Acquisitions right
is it just like customer
paino converging trend lines in terms of
Regulation and public sentiment and
which burar navigates beautifully in
highly regulated Industries including
Insurance
Railways yeah but yeah how I think about
it so I like to study these people I
know you love doing that too Study High
performers it's your thing I do that
sometimes yeah occasionally do that but
also I mean Charlie moner rest in peace
99 years old Warren Buffett I don't know
exactly in I think up there as well so I
try to think you know if Warren Buffett
and Charlie Munger were hackers in the
30s or 40s today what would they build
versus what they built in their time
with the opportunities and Technology
afforded I like to think they do some
open source because it's it's obviously
the future and um so I like the Burk for
Adams companies versus Adams versus bits
and in the industries they in I yes um I
think there would be a lot of
coordination cost and they try to
optimize for giving the companies under
them as much autonomy as possible M and
they find great leaders and they also
try to find great businesses I think
Warren Buffett said something like we
Tred to find a business a monkey could
run because someday they will or
something like that you know like what
business is so good it would survive
even bad leadership uh what we do with a
digital version of that is we lower
coordin cost between the different
products by open source so they don't
need like for woocommerce to build on
top of Wordpress it doesn't need a
meeting doesn't need to talk doesn't
even need to know the people developing
WordPress there open apis open source
there's a plug-in framework Etc so that
removes a lot of the coordination cost
that you normally get in a
multi-division company now when you say
coordination cost are you talking about
people internally say full-time
employees or are you talking about the
communities that surround some of these
things
in proprietary software if you want to
integrate with something like if I
wanted to add a new feature
to you know Mac OS or you know something
like that I can't do that now they have
apis they have operating systems Smart
Companies like slack or Shopify will
create marketplaces that you can extend
them however you're subject to their
terms right so they can change your mind
remember Twitter used to have all those
clients or Facebook did too they were
like oh we don't want this anymore
you're kicked off hey rough Tuesday
don't build on proprietary platforms
they can pull the rug and will pull the
rug at any point so an Open Source One
the rug can't be pulled two typically
they're Ultra pluggable so you can
really change every line of Wordpress
not to interrupt but would would you
mind giving a real world example of this
what this lowered integration cost looks
like in practice well let's talk about a
company like Salesforce which has done a
ton of Acquisitions you know one
criticism of like Salesforce or Cisco or
even Google sometimes their own products
don't integrate with each other as well
yeah as sometimes even external things
do so even with the best Acquisitions
and most Acquisitions fail by the way
even when you do a really good one like
maybe say YouTube sometimes the
Integrations aren't as strong or maybe
like remember when YouTube tried to do
the Google+ thing I do right every
single company was or division in Google
was like incentivized by how much
adoption Google+ got they really tried
to push it into everything like lot of
coordination cost maybe not as
responsive to users that was ultimately
unsuccessful push Google's another
example all the messaging platforms they
have like you need text just to work
with the five messaging platforms of
Google like there's examples like that
where you get duplication you get
different incentives of Executives maybe
they're more rewarded for launching new
things versus integrating things those
are coordination cost and you know this
comes up in economics terms where like
why shouldn't everyone just be a
freelancer yeah well there's some
coordination costs there it's nice to
have people employed full-time by a
company cuz then you you kind of you
don't need to rehire them every time
they're not going to be like poached by
someone else or maybe you have a gap in
the gig and they just take another gig
you know that sort of thing so I feel
like for us the common platform of Open
Source particularly WordPress allows us
to plug things in and do Acquisitions in
a way that is more set up for Success so
we have a set of products that run
directly on WordPress or get
distribution from word pressent Tumblr
so that's kind of I would say our core
area there are some which are I would
call philosophically adjacent so it's
the same philosophy day one is a great
example day one doesn't share any
technology with Tumblr or WordPress but
it's a fully encrypted local journaling
app and journaling is another word for
blogging so you can use it like I do as
like a local blog and I've I posted
every day for the past like 200 or 300
days so what does a local blog mean to
the untrained year they be like wait so
I have a Blog that I'm publishing on my
own computer how do people see it like
what what does what this is why people
usually call it a journal but when you
think about it like a Notes app like the
notes app know typically things are
undated right the the metadata
associated with them is somewhat loose
often the list is ordered by most
recently modified right so that's kind
of a UI in a blog it's reverse
chronological right we have a lot of
metadata Association so day one attaches
a date location it can store the weather
when you post it like all these
different things that kind of make it a
bit richer when it's local we usually
call it a journal just cuz that's the
concept Apple just launched a built-in
journaling app I call it a Blog because
it fundamentally if you kind of look at
those principles it's got all the same
ingredients as you post a blog reverse
chronological now why do I really like
it I prefer dated entries you know
because I'm usually taking notes each
day kind like Benjamin Franklin you know
he would kind of log everything he does
every day I do that as well I love the
search I love tagging I love all those
kind of like metadata things help me uh
find stuff and you can also Interlink
the notes which is actually pretty cool
MH so not unlike a Rome research or some
of these other obsidian you can
Interlink
things okay so we took we took a little
side alley if we if we come back to
things that you're excited about but I
didn't actually answer your question on
messaging yes like so why messaging mhm
it is not built on top of Wordpress and
it's not part of our publishing mhm kind
of thing but I do believe it is sort of
fundamental human right have private and
hopefully in the future open source
messaging and so that's again I only
want to work on things I feel like I can
work on potentially the rest of my life
mhm so you know publishing Commerce and
messaging that covers a lot of human
activity it does and if you have those
things truly free I think you have a
free society and that's also exciting to
me because how do we help bend the long
Arc towards more freedom more Liberty
across the world and Technology does
that better
then I think any sort of diplomacy or
anything else um that at least I could
work on are there any other people or
companies that stand out as being
aligned or philosophically adjacent with
the ethos you're describing well one
there's a lot more open source companies
now gitlab is a really great one led by
Sid they're actually even more open than
we are they publish like everything and
they're a public company now you know
like N9 or 10 billion doar so that's
pretty cool have those examp
think Elements which is built on the
Matrix ecosystem it's open source
messaging actually the competitor
detects beeper really awesome company I
think philosophically very aligned so
what's cool is more and more of this is
happening also there's a fun Trend where
sometimes people who did proprietary
companies M and then made a ton of money
off them what they do next is off an
open source so Jack dorsy right made a
ton of money off Twitter square one he's
taken Square to a more of a crypto
Direction he wants to enable that and
two what's he funding something called
Noster and blue sky which are two
competing open source twitters which is
really cool um Brian Acton co-founder of
WhatsApp what's he doing today he's
running signal which is an open source
nonprofit messaging app which is amazing
signal very Phil philosophically aligned
so Wikipedia Mozilla you know there's
there's a lot out there both for-profit
and nonprofit based on the very little I
know and you track this type of thing
much more than I do but in terms of
number of users per full-time employee
pre-acquisition how would you place
WhatsApp I mean it's the messaging apps
are tops yeah I think Instagram was
pretty good size with like 13 or 14 when
they sold telegram's actually pretty
amazing today signal is pretty small
team not sure the size of the WhatsApp
team now but they were very very small
when they were required it's it's
actually pretty incredible cuz messaging
there's not really any user support it's
all self ser you know they don't really
and so that those businesses can scale
quite a bit with very few people and it
also attracts like really amazing
engineer like the text team is like
incredible and so they their aspiration
is to remain like a sub 20 sub30 team
even as they grow the tens of millions
or hundreds of millions of users so how
do you you as the buyer First Resort
right the the hopefully the the aspiring
buyer of First Resort Berkshire
hathway known as automatic how do you
find these various companies or threads
to pull on or how do those people find
you people do reach out sometimes which
is always nice yeah I guess
fundamentally it's usually just driven
by me as a user mhm like I'm always
trying out new products friends
recommend it my colleagues actually of
the people we employ they tend to be
like very early adopters and very
digitally savvy so I mean that's why we
launched Bitcoin in 2012 when it was $12
like I wish I could say that that was me
being brilliant no it's one of my
colleagues he was like oh this thing's
so cool we can add support I think he
hacked it over a weekend and so all
right cool amazing I'll tell you just a
quick anecdote that I haven't mentioned
really I don't know I haven't mentioned
it anywhere because why would I but you
mentioned uh Charlie Munger rest in
peace I was I'm remembering correctly I
mean I was definitely tentatively
scheduled I think it was to interview
him the next Tuesday oh my goodness yeah
yeah he had just started doing podcast
for the first time y he he did the one
with the cisin right he did I think it
was acquired I can't recall exactly
we'll link it up it was a really great
episode yeah so for people who who
didn't get a chance we'll link to that
in the show notes I appreciated that
when he pass for someone who I've been
so obsessed with for many years when he
passed I actually had a feeling of wow
what a life well lived and so
appreciative how much he's published
over the years mhm so even though he
hadn't done a lot of these podcasts or
modern stuff he has been doing the
meetings and you know speeches and other
things for decades now so you know you
don't always have to meet your mentors I
think you talk about that as well like
sometimes it's really great to just have
the book or the speech or something like
that and it can can really live with you
you can grow up with it you can reread
it over the years like rereading Sith
harth or I know you have some things
that you read is it Zorba the Greek
Zorba the Greek is spectacular I think
we might have been together when you
found that in Greece when I found that
book of all places in Greece and
sanini and absolutely love that book yes
so that is that is one I go back to
revisit there are a lot of books I go
back to revisit awareness by Anthony
Dello would be another one very short
very fast uh I'm I'm increasingly a fan
of rereading that includes some fiction
too as you mentioned over the Greek yeah
any books you reread said Arthur why
anting story of of of Enlightenment and
journey and it's actually my Twitter bio
is I can I can think I can wait I can
fast it's a great line something like
that I probably have it out of order but
but I do them out of order too some so
it works uh what else I like to reread
essays for sure Paul Graham which essays
acceleration of addictiveness is a
really good one I haven't read that one
he has one on speed he just published
what I consider is magnum opus
apparently worked on it for like a year
I think it's called how to do great work
man that one that one's really good that
could be a book yeah it's interesting
that there's authors now blogging
essentially publishing these essays like
slate star codex Scott Alexander Shane
Parish of knowledge project like there's
these writers now that yeah really drive
a lot of folks MH you kind of I mean
your WordPress blog kind of started that
genre in a lot of ways like the longer
form like super
essays yeah yeah thousand plus blog
posts a lot of blog posts yeah and it's
sometimes easy for me to forget that
that was
essential for the
entire uh I don't know if I would call
it trajectory sort of Meandering
developing quote unquote career that
I've had like without the blog it
doesn't happen I mean the blog was
started before the first book it
continued I mean it still continues but
I have a question for you related to
blogging actually and and then
ultimately led to the podcast but
without the blog very hard to drive
people to the podcast and show notes
yeah so the the blog was both jet fuel
and Bridge and connective tissue and
still continues to be I have thought a
lot about next chapters for myself
recently I love doing the podcast I plan
on continuing doing the podcast the 10th
anniversary is coming up next April wow
10 years of on average 1.4 episodes per
week every week it's been going for a
long time wow and I wasn't the first
podcaster nor will I be the last but 10
years is is a good stretch and it's an
opportunity to pause and reflect and
think about things and when I was doing
that recently it's the end of the year I
noticed that often I I enter a game that
is new I'm not the first participant so
I'm not at the absolute Cutting Edge but
I'm on the sharp edge yeah yeah pretty
early yeah pretty early and then I stick
around for a while and I focus on it
with Incredible
enthusiasm and OCD ridiculous intensity
yeah intensity and then it it often gets
a bit crowded or saturated and then I do
something else right so the that was
true a bit with the blog but it wasn't
so much that blogging got crowded but
other opportunities surfaced and then
there was startup investing and then
that was a focus from say
2008 to 2015 then I took a Hiatus for a
while took a start vacation took
complete break from
that that was in tandem with books took
a break from the books after the 4our
chef that's when the podcast was started
right
2014 have done that for a while and now
I'm looking at various Trends various of
collective and individual behavior I'm
like okay there's a lot more zero some
Behavior things are getting very
saturated things are much more
algorithmically driven now so you can
you can effectively have an attention
rug pull right where you're you're
pursuing format X and all of a sudden
format X becomes invisible right that
could be long form audio then you get
pushed to video and then you get pushed
to short video then you get pushed to
clips and now you're in reals but you're
not appearing where you used to appear
etc etc and I've been thinking about
what to do next and have posed the
question to some folks i' be curious to
get your two
cents mean we'll talk about over dinner
tonight is what you would find
interesting for me to do next and part
of what's baked into that is as was true
with these these early chapters in each
of these new Arenas where do I have a a
particular
differentiator right an ability or
access or com comination and some weird
vent diagram that gives me an advantage
that was true with the startups because
I had the blog actually right I had the
platform and the visibility through the
first book which allowed me to become an
adviser with various companies right I
mean that that was what enabled that as
well as geographically being located in
Bay Area Bay Area although some cool
companies like Shopify or us which were
not really Bay Area companies that's
true that's true and actually a lot of
my greatest hits are from out side of
the Bay Area being in the Bay Area
created a certain like high level of
resonance with discussion in those
communities which then extended to
places like Ottawa what I've been also
thinking this is getting a little long
but I really respect your opinion on all
this stuff and I know you pay close
attention MH is that the new thing isn't
always a new thing so for instance I was
chatting I'm not going to name him
because he probably doesn't want to be
named but I was chatting with a friend
of mine and he came back to writing he
was like you can write
he's like everyone has a TV show now
effectively if you want have a podcast
you have you are building out a studio
and the truth of the matter is people
are really good really good I mean there
are some spectacularly well produced
well organized well researched well
executed shows out there and it's going
to get more crowded I mean you can use
for instance right now you can go to
chat GPT and say provide me with 10
questions in the flavor of Andrew hubman
Tim Ferris Rich Ro pick your favorite
podcaster if he or she were interviewing
so and so and it will spit out questions
and they are quite good they're they're
not bad that's hilarious actually ni so
if you have notes in front of you and
you're presentable on camera or via
audio now you're a formidable competitor
the hurdles used to be a little higher
it used to be a little harder so I've
thought about going back to writing it
is very high labor right it's there's a
reason there are so many podcasters in
the sense like when Co hit people could
have become writers when the writer
strike happened people could have all
become writers writing is really really
difficult I think so I'll interject here
if I can interject um also I felt like
your W writing process had a lot of
solitary yes and I what I observed as
you got more into podcasting other
things is you really loved the the
social piece social piece of it
interpersonal like the direct you and I
sitting across from a table inter team
doing it like also with the guest and
like that's actually a pretty cool ele
element of the format absolutely that's
a huge piece you're totally right and I
think there's part of me that has
recognized how nourishing that is for me
and I'm hesitant to go back into monk
mode in a cave staring at a blank
page I don't know do you have any any
thoughts that percolate we can certainly
continue this I'm just wondering I mean
this this at the very least this is just
like a confessional which which is nice
I love psychoanalyzing Tim it's it's one
of my
pastimes uh that is a good question and
and I think
your how you laid out how the market
changes and becomes crowded is very very
true mhm the thoughts that come to mind
is first also just as your friend like I
would love to see you focus on things
where it's not just outcome based MH cuz
as you talked about this you're like
what about the traffic what about the
you know those are more outcomes mhm so
where are there things and I think
actually podcasting is true for this
where the journey itself is very
rewarding for you totally if no one
listened to this this a still a fun
afternoon absolutely you know and we're
kind of just recording what we might do
anyway which is kind of neat best job
ever so that's I think that's nice I
think actually I find writing although
it can be unfun at the time so rewarding
afterwards type two fun yeah type two
fun and so I wonder as well if that's
not sure how much you're writing right
now I know you did some fiction stuff
and some comic stuff and like that's
interesting esps of creativity and those
also when when I bleed out of
non-fiction is when it gets easier for
me to
collaborate which maybe is maybe is the
way I go not necessarily fiction per se
but just different formats that would be
an ability to experiment I mean the
other thing is I'm not going to have the
right attribution maybe it's Neil
Strauss maybe it's Seth Goen but anyone
who's really been
consistently productive in the sense of
words on pages the vast majority at some
point I've heard say there's no such
thing as writer writer Block it's when
your standards are too high you just
need to lower your standards until you
can get out of rough draft and I'm of
course grossly generalizing but it's
along those lines and so I've also
thought part of the reason that writing
is so intimidating to me is I look at
some of my blog posts and they're not
quite Tim Urban God bless his soul you
know they're not 50,000 word posts but
they're long I mean these are
significant Investments of of time and
energy and maybe the answer is you know
what just like you can't write more than
four paragraphs that's it some
constraints closer to say some of Seth's
shorter pieces even shorter the much
shorter than Paul Graham I'll give a nod
to Paul also I have I think it's the top
idea in your mind that is one of his
essays that I have bookmarked so it's
visible in my browser there there are
others of course I mean the make
schedule manager schedule or manager
schedule's maker schedule which I think
is a perennial reminder worth paying
attention to so I've thought about the
constraints maybe making it shorter but
I I do think to underscore what you said
the social piece is a big one right how
do you make it social so if I were to
brainstorm about your blog yeah some
things I'd recommend trying are like
what would a really amazing comment
section look like mhm you know what if
that were really jazzed up like maybe
more like forums maybe more like
building Community you know you've
experim with events before and I think
that's actually pretty exciting I found
a lot of value cuz I've been blogging
now for like 20 years and some gardening
so meaning returning to some older
pieces mhm some of which still get
traffic M and do the links work you know
what's the update to it what's the sort
of like do I at the top do I link to a
new thing does this inspire me to write
like a new version of this that's
interesting really lovely actually and
feels like you're creating a corpus
you're creating a body of work even the
old stuff reflects some of your best
today thinking and being able to return
to the old Tim yeah or when I return to
the old Matt like it's often sometimes
surprising you know like I'm like wow I
said this like sometimes I'm pleasantly
surprised sometimes I'm like H I was
young but then maybe that's a cool sort
of Grist for something new yeah like hey
I said this 15 years ago like I've
learned so much since then and here's
maybe you're at my 15yo version and here
is what kind of changed my mind I guess
we have a list of change things you
change your mind on community yeah and
also I think multimodal formats it's
kind of like you're going to take this
podcast and slice it up for like Tik Tok
shorts reals whatever you're putting it
on I think people don't do that enough
into blog post you mean converting
things into blog post or or taking blog
posts and turning them into other I
think every podcast you do has 10 to 15
blog posts worth of stuff in it oh I
agree easily easily you've known me for
a long time so I'm going to start with
my
fears not all the amazing ways this
could go right let me talk about all the
terrible things that could happen I have
I guess what I want to be very cautious
of is the siren song of high volume
content farming right because I have
seen people who are very good they're
very smart but they're really video
first just churning out just like a a an
assembly line of hot dogs of content in
every form including text right so how
would you think about quality assurance
on that we've actually talked about this
we brainstormed a bit on your site M
around if you imagined tim. blog almost
like a Wikipedia MH where each guest was
like a topic and that could be referred
to in many episodes and so I I think
that might be the antidote to this to
where the content the transcripts
everything right how this works on blogs
is kind of clunky right now I think you
have like a post for the show and then a
post for the transcript no script or
transcript and like that should honestly
be one URL like it should be it's clunky
in part because it's it's a lot of stuff
right the show notes are very extensive
they're long and then the transcripts
are very extensive so it turns into an
enormous it's basically a book right it
turns into a a book length I would love
if the transcript tied to a player video
Andor audio so you can click on it and
listen you could listen and read at the
same time like you know sort of like a
karaoke like scrolling through I mean I
use YouTube that way with transcripts
yeah they surprising surprisingly good I
would love for everything to be linked
autolink so anytime a book is mentioned
anytime a essay is mentioned that goes
to a page which pivots that's I want to
see every time Paul Graham's been
mentioned across all of your how many
episodes now close to 700 yeah that's
interesting I've been invoking Paul
Graham like candyman candyman candyman
for years now but as as of yet we have
not had a podcast conversation maybe
something I I don't think he does that
many he does very few he had a he had a
conversation with Tyler Cowen I love
that one it was hilarious which was
hilarious which was hilarious and I have
the utmost respect for both of those
guys Tyler is also a one of a kind he
has stylistically produced a very novel
and helpful show there's no one like
Tyler like he is an inimitable style the
rapid fire question the rapid fire the
rapid fire no follow-ups
of different things I'm kind of
terrified about going on a show he's
he's the reason I started blogging he
was a big influence okay so I'm not sure
I knew this tell he's been doing
marginal revolutions for like I think
over 20 years yeah and when I was in
high school one of the super cool things
I did you know you did wrestling I I did
this um economics competition run by the
Federal Reserve Bank sexy I know let me
tell you you must have been beating the
girls off with a stick uh somewhat you
know the my macroeconomic insights were
not quite um driving the interest I
hoped for since hints me getting the
computers and Jazz and stuff so um but
we did this economics competition and it
provided it really opened a lot of
opportunities for me I got to go to
Washington DC me GRE what does it mean
to have an economics competition I mean
this like econometrics mathematics
competition like what do we talk about
it was an interesting format so have you
heard of the fomc the Federal Open
Market Committee no so that is the
Committee of Bank presidents and Federal
Reserve leaders that come together to
determine What's called the FED funds
rate which basically trickles down to be
the interest rates man I bet a lot of
people would be like to be in that room
wouldn't they yeah it's a it's a pretty
cool meeting and they're basically it's
like the Illuminati and they've been
doing an amazing job too like think of
all the recessions we've avoided and all
the problems that don't have so it was I
think fulker who said like their job is
take the punch bowl away as the party
starts going by turning up the interest
rates slows down the economy so they
have a lot of levers and some new ones
as well so the first 15 minutes is we
would do a mock meeting so like you
would be Greenspan I'd be Ben beraki
like we kind of pretend roleplay yeah
the different presidents and we'd read
their essays and speeches and things to
try to like have their style or their
point of view and Based on data up to
when the competition started so if like
new economic data was released that
morning we might incorporate into the
presentation do 15 minutes of that and
then second 15 minutes is they can ask
you any question about economics they
want and do you have to still be in
character or is this this is more
they're qu you as like the five high
school students and that part was really
fun because a little more
improvisational I love Q&A and Houston
just weirdly ended up being one of the
most competitive districts in the
country so the first year we just got
creamed by the way I went to Arts High
School so we' never won an academic
competition ever you know like Beyonce
went there Robert glass like we weren't
known for academics uh but had this
awesome teacher Scott Roman
who was like an economics teacher he
like hey let's do this so first year we
got creamed second year we won Houston
Ron the region and then so second year
they're just like all right we're giving
you guys all the roids we're giving you
guys all the Special Top Secret Chinese
training programs how did you just get
go from getting cream to winning in the
second year yeah I credit the teacher a
lot you know he he it was first period
so it was the same class every morning
we all picked different newspapers like
Financial Times Wall Street Journal we'd
read them every morning we discuss then
at the time high school so it's you 17
18 probably or 16 17 he had us teach
each other a lot of things and you know
you really learn something when you have
to teach it so he'd be like Scott or
irum like you know teach about you know
some macroeconomics concept and we kind
of rotate through that and then a lot of
practicing you know we get together on
weekends over the summer we went to DC
as like a summer program but anyway got
to meet Alan Greenspan which is pretty
cool yeah the followup to that is is the
year after there was a conference um
hosted by the Dallas Federal Reserve
Bank honoring Milton
Freedman and because one of my teammates
had gone to like intern for the Federal
Reserve and actually maybe Mr Roman
might have started Consulting for them
or something like that I got an invite
as a kid at this point I haven't done
WordPress I'm just going to University
of Houston like barely passing my
political science major like so I got to
go to this and Tyler con was there and
his blog actually was one of the big I I
mentioned the newspapers I probably
learned more from marginal revolutions
than I did from Financial Times
textbooks Etc and he has textbooks and
stuff so he was there and this is
actually I blogged about this and so
it's on my blog a post about meeting him
and I asked him for his viice and he
said write every day and I've basically
been doing that ever since that seem
seems to have worked out it's kind of
cool also now that I can look up this
history so yeah and I'm going to do a
bit of followup on this which
is I I got 14 more things I'm excited
about I know I know I we're going to
we're going to get to we're going to get
to the other things maybe I have an idea
for how we're going to do that but with
the economics competitions you said
barely passing in political science and
I know you credited the teacher and said
he was an excellent teacher but what was
it about the the economics the
competition the teacher or the
combination that made you give so much
to that versus other classes well at one
point I got kicked off the team got
kicked off which was um it really worked
like I get it now the psychology of it
so um you know I I think by a lot of
ways you would sort of rank things or
look at strengths I definitely should
have been on this five person team MH
however as actually you experience today
I'm not always the most timely person
this was the first class of the day
yeah so I was laate a lot to school and
at one point this teacher like kicked me
off the team and I was like this is
ridiculous what do you mean like we got
to win like what's this what's happening
and then he made the challenge to me so
his other thing which was actually true
I didn't really appreciate this into my
20s he was like you have no physical
tone or any like you don't like I just
thought I was a brain in a vat like I
didn't work out by the way the school
had no gym we had no sports like so he
was like to get back on the team you
need to run two miles with me cuz he was
a jogger and I think he got me a book
like called like Body for Life or
something one of these early Bill
Phillips I think back in the day and so
that was what I had to do getb on the
team I had like two months to run these
two miles or whatever and and I had to
show up on time so I started showing up
on time and then you know we did the the
Run by the way I really not trained but
I just kind of like made it through like
sheer force of will cuz when you're 17
you can just kind of destroy your body
anyway and so I did that and I was back
on the team that was you know we went on
to winning these competitions and
everything so it was but that was
motivating to me like kind of the harsh
consequences being kicked off yeah and
also you know being my sort of day thing
at the school was jazz saxophone and I
think music all performance can be very
rigorous you know you get first second
third fourth chair you get ranked you
compete you like I feel like that
feedback loop and also the Performing so
being on stage breath control TR the
competition as well yeah the economics
yeah you have to perform performing like
when I look back at like what sort of
set me up for business later especially
at a young age I think it was musical
theater Jazz performance like that sort
of stuff was was really huge amazing so
the way we got here CU I've I've learned
to rewind you were saying things should
all be automatically linked like every
mentioned of Paul Graham in the podcast
and then I mentioned candy Candyman
Tyler Cowen and then we ended up where
we ended up anything else I want to
continue to brainstorm this with you
just in terms and we can continue at
dinner just in terms of what experiments
might look like to do
things
differently where I am somehow well
positioned doing something that cannot
be replicated the next day by a thousand
people I'm interested in it trying to
answer that question more kind of blue
ocean versus red ocean kind of stuff
right but let's come back to your list
of exciting things sure and and why
don't we why don't we do this we can go
through some quickly too yeah mention a
couple this is this we can sort of swoop
in this is a quick one and I mentioned
already
USBC like if you know me you know how
much I love cables you love cables and
yeah ier and the fact it is hard for me
to convey verbally how much Matt likes
different kind of cables and containing
the cables and organizing the cables it
is giting the cables I like you know
give someone a good cable like they they
think of you every time they charge up
it's true I was just using your or your
external battery pack that you gave me
for my birthday the other day and I was
like oh that yeah what do you get the
guy who does that has everything yeah
the coolest battery pack you know like
so uh cuz I've tested 20 of them so you
know I know you've put in the mileage
all right so USBC everything's going
USBC now iPhone is USBC I'm down to like
I think one or two things in my life
that are not USBC and it's glorious so
I'm very excited about
that um I'm really excited about AI all
right like honestly it's the programming
of AI like the prompt engineering you
can't really call it programming spell
casting yeah it's like casting spells
it's ridiculous and when you hear a good
prompt like you just said it's like oh
that's so cool mhm and it's kind of open
sourish and that not really I guess you
could have prepared day prompts people
do but there's actually sites now where
people buy and sell prompts which is so
cool yeah it's wild so it's kind of like
a new form of programming coming online
that for me is as exciting as when I
first learned the progr program M cuz it
it like unlocks these
superpowers and it's also just
fascinating like the things you think
would be easy like driving the cars
turns out to be really hard stuff you
thought would be really hard like
writing poetry like Shakespeare it just
kind of spits off in seconds at all you
know like turn this podcast make it all
rhyme you know it could do that and
that's kind of ridiculous Co okay so on
the AI side this is of course
been a
Topic in the Zeitgeist for a bit now a
lot of people are talking about AI you
unlike me have some technical chops and
you know how to
code I would love to know if you have
any
controversial there's no emotional
veillance to this right or maybe
uncommon thoughts
around AI or or questions that you're
asking things you're looking for that
maybe are
not what I would get in response from
you know 100 people I wouldn't get 50 of
them telling me the same thing that's
hard cuz I don't know what 50 people
would tell you but I'll tell you one
thing get the idea I mean they would
tell me probably what's what's in the
news cycle or in the media cycle even if
it's within the niche community of
fintech on Twitter right they would they
would have those inputs I'll tell you
what I kind of hate about it which is
that it's gotten me addicted to Twitter
again which I had broken ai ai because
like there's the FOC you hear of you
know the Sam mman the Greg brogans Etc
and there's just as interesting and good
stuff on random Anonymous Twitter
accounts with like an Anime Avatar and
so it's a little ridiculous like a lot
of the top researchers have these alts
they call them or like other accounts
will they share more stuff and it's
redirected a lot of my reading so I I
follow a lot of these do you have you
find out stuff like within hours of it
happening and they link to a lot of
scientific papers so this is an area I
don't understand as well so I've been
reading a lot of papers and learning a
lot about it is there a place where
people can
find a group or a list of these people
or is
that that's a taboo right no no there
probably are I don't publish any list
cuz I don't use the Twitter list
function or X list function I think
Sayan banister might she she was very
early she was like a first hund user of
like CH gbt mid Journey like so she just
good for her oh she's definitely one of
these people to follow okay so I say
Canan banister as someone great to
follow Canan banister we'll link to cyan
in the in the show notes and so you find
one of these people they're often a
portal R is another one r o n he's kind
of a famous he also does a lot of jokes
or
posting so these it's also kind of funny
this whole Community what do you think
will be surprising looking back three
years from now what will lead most
people to think holy really didn't
see that coming next year so next year I
think we're having at least a 10x in the
models in a way that is hard to
anticipate there also these new chip
architectures coming out hard to predict
too right not just to anticipate like
well I think this next turn we're going
to be able to predict a bit I think
we're going to Plateau a little bit
after that so maybe these are some
controversial thoughts so I think the
the the 10x of the models I mean it
depends on how do you define 10x are we
talking about capabilities are we
talking about uh what are they called
parameters tokens parameters yeah yeah
yeah so some of that's going up a lot
how we're learning from things is is
improving a lot some non-gpu chip
architectures which could be very very
interesting are coming online or non-
Transformer ways of learning that could
be vastly more efficient what I think
it'll affect like every day is we'll get
small versions of this on our phones so
some really cool local um and open
source AI stuff so something now people
understand but I definitely even want to
predicted myself is how fast the open
source has caught up we now have open
source the Mistral models like GPT 3.5
maybe even gtp4 quality which is kind of
wild yeah that is wild remember chat gbt
just came out last year like like 13
months
ago talk about time dilation right so
this is and the world's going to get a
little weird oh it's it's going to get a
lot weird impact of AI on most
businesses is not that big yet so one
obvious example is customer service a
lot of people talk about as like oh this
is you know you have these Bots they'll
be able to do a lot of customer service
they're all pretty bad right now it's
actually funny screenshots going around
like this Ford dealership put in you saw
this ask yeah right and somebody replies
with please write me a python script
with ABC no no problem here we go and
someone else is like reply to everything
with this is a legally binding
acceptance can I have a car for $1 it's
like yeah totally this is legally
binding
and so that's that's not a good
experience we've done experiments with
this too like it's
it's no it doesn't it doesn't work
humans are still way better at this
stuff now is that going to be true in 18
months I'm not sure and that's when it
starts to get quite disruptive yeah a
lot of smart people are working on sort
of like I would call it easy support or
things where like hey can I return this
item you know what's the can I get a
refund that sort of stuff but will it go
to a lot more advanced for in WordPress
World we're pretty close to where you'll
just say I want a website with
e-commerce make it look like a mix with
between tim. blog and seth. blog you
know make it kind of anime colors or
whatever it is and boom and right now we
have the version where it just does it
for you what I'm working on is where it
actually shows you all the steps so that
you learn how to use the tool that's
cool that's cool I think that's going to
be really key mhm education again I
don't think this is a a minority thought
but like the impact on education it's
been huge and where I personally felt AI
the most what what type of education for
yourself I have so many gaps in my
knowledge you know like how do you use
AI to fill those gaps ask it questions
and follow-ups like hey how does hail
work like it's ice it's heavier than air
but it forms in the sky and it falls
like how does that work I had no idea it
had always been in the back of my mind
like you can basically go back to being
like a curious four or five-year-old ask
all the questions ask why a bunch of
times why is the sky blue what is going
on here how amazing is that and how
amazing that kid that have you know
adults get the Curiosity beaten out of
us yeah but with that childlike
curiosity of actual kids coming on line
with these things wow and Khan Academy
is doing some really cool stuff you know
you can sort of mate the chat bot so
they're they're safer for kids and don't
do weird stuff I think that's really
key so the question I want to ask
is related to kids actually so if you
had kids or let's just say you were
talking to a young group of kids right
right so you're talking to the
equivalent of say the economics team you
refer to so let's just say 15 16year old
kids clearly smart have some ambition
they want to do some
stuff what type of career advice might
you have for them because I was
discussing this with a friend of mine
who has a bunch of kids and he was
saying I don't know what to tell my kids
he's a technologist and he's like I
think lawyers he's like right now we've
basically we've I can't remember the
exact AI that he's using it's not chat
GPT but he's using a legal specific AI
to draft almost all of their agreements
I don't want to dox them so I'm not
going to give too much more detail but
like this guy's very smart I mean he he
he is he's using that to replace a lot
of at least kind of first round drafting
now there are many reasons to have
lawyers and law firms besides just
drafting so to be clear if you need a
privatized Army to inflict God knows
what then it's a different different
conversation but then you have many
aspects of AI that are going to disrupt
jobs I mean I mean they really just are
or people are going to have to Bob and
weave despite what some of our mutual
friends might say about like no one's
ever going to lose a job and so on I
don't believe it so what might you
advise to someone now and they could be
young or somebody who's just thinking
about a career pivot like what how do
you AI proof yourself or at least kind
of put on an eight-point harness so you
have some defensibility what are your
thoughts the one maybe this is something
I changed my mind on but it is one on my
list is I used to really advocate to
learn to code you these can write pretty
good code now I've gone back and forth
so if you had asked me like 3 months ago
I was like n don't learn to code anymore
now I think I'm back to it's worth to
learn to code the same way it might be
useful to learn a martial art even if
you're not going to be defending
yourself every day as like part of your
livelihood like there's there's
something intrinsically good studying
the humanities Etc so I think learning
code can teach you to understand what's
going on with computers in a way that I
think in AI world will also be very
useful I would tell kids to play with
this stuff a ton you know the prompt
engineering the the playing with it
learning how to learn here's something I
know you're very passionate about feels
pretty Timeless
mhm and I'd probably point to that great
work essay by Paul Graham he talks a lot
about
ambition and how important it is what
what you're doing like what's your drive
are you going to leave a dent in the
universe or do or do your best trying
you know yeah and I feel like that's
really really really important I'm
actually very optimistic about future
Generations tell you something I changed
my mind on yeah let's do it we'll jump
around a little bit it's kind of two
parts one I I used to be worried that
like we were going to have too many
people on earth mhm right this great
book Kevin Kelly recommended called
empty Planet basically says we're not
going to have enough people population
has already peaked in most developed
countries I think the US is the only
nuclear superpower with a growing
population over the next 30 Years what
do you attribute that to well for us
it's just immigration so if we mess that
up we're going to lose this whole toast
it's a big competitive Advantage for us
when you think about when the best
people in the world want to send their
kids to school here and stay here mhm if
we mess that up we're I think we have
some other Advantage Geographic and
resource wise but like yeah that's a
really important one I had personally
chosen not to have kids 7 years ago now
I decided six years ago like I'm not
going to have kids the rest of my life
sort of built my life around that been
rethinking that somewhat maybe it's the
rip old age of 40 may also knowing that
we're not going to have enough people in
the world it's kind of exciting to think
you know someone born today in 18
years what are they doing yeah like for
most of the past hundred years you could
predict a few things like there's
colleges which have been around for many
hundreds of years like there's a few
things that have worked I don't know if
an 18e is like you have a really super
smart precocious kid you're going to
want to send them to a Harvard or
Princeton or like any of these things
mhm I think the world might have shifted
so much that that's just like a
radically different thing that kind of
makes me a little optimistic and curious
about it what what are the reasons do
you have for feeling optimistic that's I
think a Counterpoint to a lot of the
dystopian narratives that people will be
interested to hear more about you're
optimistic kind of by default is that
fair to say like you sort of that way
lean optimistic to begin with but I
sometimes B this is a big change in the
conversation that that you and I had
round kits like this is my first time
hearing about it this is like that's why
I told you I had some new stuff for you
yeah you certainly do for this as well
has just been inspired I've now 13 or 15
godchildren and so like seeing some of
them and being able to be in their lives
a bit has been just so rewarding so cool
to see them like download new
information that whole thing I mean this
is not Noel at all all like by the way
every person I know as a parent has been
saying this like Matt you don't
understand I'm like okay maybe I'm
starting to get it through my thick head
a little bit why optimistic I know that
technology is somewhat neutral or can be
a double-edged sword can be used for
good and bad I guess I have a core
assumption to my optimism which is a
fundamental goodness of human nature mhm
and this is actually a big split some
people think humans are you know the
Hobs and life is nasty British and short
like or what's the the survival stuff we
read like Neil strauss's book where like
emergency we're two weeks of food away
from everyone just going crazy and like
I and I think growing up in Houston
through hurricanes and stuff I saw some
of these disaster situations including
when like there was no power and how
people came together was quite inspiring
so is there evil in the world yes I mean
we see this with some of the autocratic
leaders and things especially of like
regular people not these like crazy evil
terrible people like I I would feel
pretty good about being like teleported
to any place in the world and talking to
someone that's kind of cool and then
especially when we figure out economic
stuff and can like remove some of these
base level issues survival issues which
we largely have in the developed world
and arguably even in the whole world
like the blockers are typically
political or these autocrats we could
feed everyone in the world easily right
now the blockers are usually political
that's exciting M and so and then the
final thing is just working on it the
best way to predict the future is to
invent it yeah so there's a way I want
the web to work and I work on it and
it's worked like we we got a third of
the websites on this thing that that's
cool and that's forcing the proprietary
people to open up more other stuff like
you have a worldview and like you
interview people who you want your
readers to and listeners to listen to
because they'll get influenced by it MH
I don't think you'd bring someone on
here that you thought was going to like
mess up their mind or head them down a
wrong direction I've not I've not been
been seduced by the dark side just yet
right and so that's that's part of
changing how the world works yeah
totally and I do use the podcast for
that for sure and the books and
everything like how many people have you
met that are like my life changed
somehow yeah yeah yeah that's inventing
the future who is if you just been
passive yeah that wouldn't have been a
ripple in the pond what is the H you
know what we can we can look it up and
put in the show notes it's not touring
but the best way to predict the future
is to invent it do you remember the
attribution on that I want to say Alan K
Alan K that is it it's Alan K what a
great line and how true what else are
you excited about or have you changed
your mind we may come back to the kids
thing I'm still like in shock over this
this is amazing I know we'll talk about
it more yeah yeah it's developing you
know I say like I don't know what that
looks like for me if it's traditional
non-traditional but we just announced I
just did my state of the word which is
the annual speech I do is like State of
the Union mhm and there's something I'm
very very excited about next year we're
working on we're calling it data
liberation front one reason I think
proprietary Services have gotten a lot
more popular mhm is they do subtle
things to lock people in remember we
talked about the messaging earlier yeah
and some some of the CMS spaces like Wix
don't even provide an export so they
really it's like a roach motel you'll
check in you can't check out so what
we're doing with this data Liberation
frund is creating an open source
directory that provides two-way like
import of all this data so whether
that's in e-commerce and another page
builder CU there all these different
page builders for WordPress besides
Gutenberg everything and then once it's
in WordPress you can get it into
anything else that you want because
WordPress is kind of universally
supported our formats we're also
improving the WordPress to Wordpress
migration format so we have an export
but it actually isn't great in that like
it doesn't moving the files and the
plugins and everything is still a pain
in the butt so we're going to make that
really really easy and so my hope is by
like radically lowering the friction
it'll help make the web kind of force
everything to be more bit more open data
Liberation Front catchy name so it's
it's in a sense this may be a terrible
analogy but it's like a Google Translate
for Content management and Technology
right like from anything to
anything and then from that next top to
whatever else it increases competition
MH this also means that if you're in
WordPress everyone else is going to do
this too but I think this is ultimately
really good for users MH and when you
think of lock in like music Services how
hard is it to move your playlist in
between the Music Services someone
actually built something for this that
lock in is I think not user friendly
what are some other ways that you would
like to see the technology world or just
Technologies stirred up in this way
where if if one person or company were
to do X it would sort of catalyze a
bunch of mimicry or SL competition that
would be ultimately better for users and
Humanity SL film the blank you know what
I'm grasping for right yeah yeah mhm
we've talked about messaging you know
app stores are opening up now it's been
some judgments against Google around
billing systems and other things m a big
reason I think the world's from
proprietary the past 15 years has been
mobile platforms which are way more
locked down than
desktops everything has to go through
their App Store you can't just run
arbitrary software on your phone um you
will be able to do more stuff like that
over the next few years so could you
just walk me through an example so so I
understand what you mean sure what it
looks like and what it could look like
like So currently what the issues are
and then what it could look like yeah so
today every app on your phone has to go
through the App Store so they go through
an approval process sometimes apple is
slow at approving things sometimes they
kick stuff out Tumblr got kicked out
yeah you know they typically take a
pretty big cut of payments they force
you to use their subscription systems
and they take 15 or 30% of it
which breaks some business models so
that's why like for a while I think they
made exceptions but when you subscribe
to like Spotify or Netflix through your
phone it would cost more if you did it
on the web because they have to pay that
cut and the exceptions they make are
somewhat arbitrary so for example if you
buy a book on Amazon they don't make you
use their payments or take a 15 or 30%
cut right because the the margins or
when you order an Uber they're not doing
that when you're tipping through Uber
they don't take a cut it just goes
direct to the driver but we added a
tipping feature on Tumblr which again
we're not taking any money from it it's
like just money going direct between the
people MH and they made us charge a fee
on it like a subscription it was like a
subscription thing and they made us
charge a fee and it's like ah well wow
now like if you're charging like a $6 a
month subscription to your blog that
becomes four bucks a month and then I
still have to process the credit card
even or do some something else over that
so like just got very messy mhm so so
that's an example so that's going to
change or it might change yeah I think
so I think regulatory pressure is going
to force them to open up you've always
been able to like jailbreak your phone
or you might sideload things using like
something like test flight you can do
testing apps yeah totally but it's not
really a broad commercial thing I'm also
thinking about this for text you know
text the multi messaging app they might
not like MH so what would it look like
if it's blocked by the app stores how
can we still get it in the of the people
mhm so do you have any ideas that you
can share or is that to to inside plan a
is working with the networks and like
just saying hey like we want to support
your business model we're not trying to
change any of that we're just trying to
provide this power user tool and there's
a lot of prior art for this in like
email clients right you can use Gmail
with macmail or with you know superum or
any other things right it's just and
their business is fine yeah I guess
carrot stick I I don't know if we have a
stick against these companies but like
you know working with politicians
working with our user base to like you
know do petitions MH I don't know maybe
I'll Camp outside Apple's office do a
hunger strike at one Infinity way or
like you know I really believe in this
stuff like because it's user Centric so
what is the what's the thing that gets
them to do the thing that is really ripe
are their users MH you know what could
change what company could change as all
as Apple yeah and the reason I talk
about them a lot isn't because I don't
like them it's because I hold them in
the very highest esteem mhm I love Apple
a lot mhm they're like a$3 trillion
company now but they still act like an
underdog sometimes mhm and so I think a
lot about what would a
benevolent sort of Elder Statesman of
apple look like mhm if they sort of
acted like hey we won yeah we have
hundreds of billions of dollars in the
bank there's very little that could hurt
them except
hubis companies don't die from
competition they usually die from
suicide side and so whether it's flying
too close to the Sun or trying to over
optimize the last penny from everything
in ways that lock and users are on sort
of Freedom promoting I could see that
hurting them majorly so I want to see
the opposite I want to see like a really
vibrant Google Apple Microsoft Etc and
actually Microsoft is probably the best
example of this has become used to be
quite competitive quite anti-competitive
obviously MH and has become quite
benevolent over the past decade and one
of the most amazing tournament rounds
and runs yeah really remarkable Embrace
of Open Source making things super user
Centric like they did a lot of really
cool cool stuff there and I think that's
the playbook for all these big tech
companies what are some of the Lesser
known tools of
competition or like invisible tools of
competition in the sense that someone or
platform or fill in the blank larger
company
making say a a messaging service break
5% of the time or be 10% slower right
that's that's an sort of invisible means
of Leverage I would have to imagine
there are examples of under the umbrella
term of say privacy you could also see
some
really incredible sort of competitive
pressuring SLC crushing SL Fillin the
blank so I'm just I'm just wondering as
someone who's worked in technology
understands technology as an operator an
individual contributor can code and who
also is right in the middle of the
switch box so you see a lot you get to
test a lot that is behind the scenes
what are some of the Lesser known tools
of sort of invisible competition there's
a lot of dials so I'll talk about things
that are publicly known and people been
caught about yeah U versus all the
secret things we did no
okay X Twitter under Elon Musk got
caught you know every single link you
click on Twitter goes through t.co a
redirect service yep to certain media
sites and other things they were
inserting like a 5 to 10c delay H again
every little bit of friction
particularly on mobile people just press
the back button they go back to the
Tweet list so like it's it's incredible
and there's studies around this like
every 100 milliseconds the page takes a
load like lower conversion Etc what else
has been caught Google got caught for
they created this format called amp
accelerated mobile Pages it was to
designed to compete make Mobile faster
we actually supported it wholeheartedly
M and they did it kind of Open Source
and everything like that some documents
leaked that basically said that and it's
funny cuz I think the people working on
AMP didn't even know this I think they
were actually like True Believers in the
sort of improving the web type of thing
certainly we didn't know this but there
was something in amp that also like
locked I'm not going to get this right
but like blocked header bidding or
something basically made it harder for
other advertising networks to run on
these pages and way that benefited
Google and I think Google particularly
has sharp elbows around advertising
stuff mhm the greatest money maker and
the history of the internet you mean I I
get why they yeah um and the duopoly
there of them and Facebook them and meta
is entrenched by regulation as well so
Bill Gurley has this amazing
presentation have you seen this the I'm
not sure which one I've seen a few of
his presentations he has a new one it's
basically about regulatory capture mhm
it's the name is a number of miles like
2791 he kind of goes through a number of
examples of where you know whether it's
covid test if you go to this is one
example you go to Walgreens or CVS here
there's three covid test Brands and each
one cost like $21.99 this is you know a
couple years later in Europe they're
like five bucks for two mhm and
apparently the US blocks all the
European
manufacturers and again these assay
tests are like very basic Technologies
like nothing new like you know what's
happening there mhm and he kind of digs
into it and oh the regulator used to
work at two of these companies actually
like that's interesting like how's this
all work so how regulatory capture and
he tells his story of like he was trying
to Lobby around something and then the
politician was like can I have a meeting
he's like oh yeah I'll come to you he's
like wow that's like I'm on the west
coast he's like no no I'll come to you
set up a conference room then someone
calls him like Hey we do these like a
fundraiser it's usually like five grand
a
seat and he's like okay and they're like
well then they call him back he gets
like six people together and then
they're like you need a bigger
room all of a sudden becomes 10 people
and and then the the next thing was
something like we'd love all the people
who are who are married for their
Partners to donate as well and he's like
I don't have enough seats in the room
he's like oh they don't need to come to
the meeting this is like a literal story
that happened to him and he was fighting
for something really good it was around
Municipal Wi-Fi mhm you know and it was
being blocked by the telecom companies
the Comcast and Verizon of the world
were blocking this so it's a great
presentation I would say that's a a
followup for everyone listening we'll
link to that but I think that's also
something that companies can do I know
for a fact they hire opposition research
they publish they sponsor academics and
things to publish this companies tied up
in China or this time you know like it's
all happening to each other all the time
mostly among big Tech I would say
startups don't do this at all medium
Tech doesn't do this at all well is that
because they are lawful good to use D
and D parlament or is it just simply
because they don't have the resources I
would say yeah maybe they don't have the
resources my my Steelman for why the big
companies do this is they also get
attacked a lot in probably really
underhanded ways so it's it's as much
defense as offense MH and so that would
be my sort of like charitable
interpretation of why they do some of
these things mhm do you have any
security or basic security or privacy
recommendations for Average Joe or Jane
well I guess I don't want to insult my
listeners but just like somebody like me
I'm not technical right but if you were
to say yeah one thing you want to be
really careful about is this like on my
on personal devices and computers like
just a lot of people do X you should
really do the opposite of X the easy
stuff make sure your apps and operating
system are always up to date yeah I
actually get really excited it's like
one of the first things I do in the
morning is like load the app updates mhm
so make yourself excited about it very
important with browsers like Chrome too
yeah there's a lot of actively exploited
stuff out there to you know good
passwords I think you've talked about
this I like password manager like one
password there's also this new thing
coming out called pass keys
you know I have seen this and I don't
know what it means so I would actually
love a a one1 this is kind of a new
thing for your audience like if a server
supports pass Keys you should switch to
it so basically it's a technology which
eliminates passwords use like a secure
key exchange and as a user what you'll
see is that you just log in with
scanning your face or something and it's
kind of built into the OS in a really
secure way and it's Unique you know like
thing that breaks my heart is when
people use the same password on multiple
Services never do that
all my passwords are like super random
like 40 character like I I couldn't tell
you if I wanted to but you know you
generate them and that's kind of what
this does in a better way except do you
mind getting into the weeds for a second
just on a technical level what are we
talking about are these kind of like
private keys and private messaging like
PG pgp am I making that up I think pgp
stands for pretty good privacy this is
like a key exchange yeah okay what is
that what is that yeah what's actually
happening I know this is probably going
to get way above my pay grade quickly
but password I understand mhm well to
the extent that I think I understand and
this is actually I'm not sure the exact
length of the key or or anything like
that but imagine it like you have a
really unique super long password like
maybe like a couple thousand characters
MH that is then stored in the secure
Enclave on your device MH and so one
password can also support these but
basically it kind of like gets people to
use random passwords and it creates a
better UI because they're logging in
with their their face or their
fingerprint or something mhm M so say
that's probably the best way to describe
it what the protocol is doing is the
browsers now support this as a standard
and so they do like a challenge response
effectively so if you've you've used
like SSH before probably yeah you can do
that with a key so you can type in a
password or you can have a public key
stored on the server M which is not
sensitive someone could have access to
your public key and not get to anything
and then your private key which is
secret and there's a a calculation done
between those which says oh this is
really him or the the person with the
key got it okay P case to revisit what
else are you excited about Dr melan W
we're Camp Asia this is actually a joint
thing yes this is let's let's talk about
this so this is this is something I am
very excited about and I need to finesse
some details to make sure it's going to
work but what are we talking about we've
had some pretty epic travel Adventures
it's been a while it has been a while
we've hung out more in like home bases
and things but they kind of traveling
we've been all over we've been to
Vietnam yeah been to
Turkey
Greece been all over and actually the
only time I've set foot in Taiwan which
is where we're campasia is this year was
We were connecting to Vietnam actually
an amazing story there a cool Tim story
as well um like there was something
wrong with our tickets and they weren't
letting us bored I remember and this was
kind of early like not everyone spoke
English or something and you like
started breaking out some Mandarin I
remember somehow got us on the I don't I
still don't know what you said remember
I remember that God I haven't thought
about that in forever I still have a
photograph that you took in a park late
night in in Vietnam of this little kid
with a cute hat with break dancers in
the background I still have that on my
on my bookshelf brings back some great
memories yes I've never been to Taiwan
so work campia March 7th through 9th you
graciously agreed to come and part of
like the pitch which also I want to do
is like take a few days off afterwards
and explore the country yeah yeah we'll
probably get in on the last day or
something cuz I'll do a few days with
all the WordPress stuff and then I just
explore the food like I've heard so many
good things about Taiwan it's also one
of those places that kind of like Hong
Kong 15 years ago like maybe you could
the visit this is a a geographic
geopolitical Hot Spot yeah it is a just
an open there are a lot of open
questions around Taiwan especially over
the next few years so I think it's like
a kind of a perfect time to be there
yeah but say we got to figure out what
you're doing at working at beijia if you
want to do like a Q&A I can interview
you or give a talk on yeah something
you've learned like it's a cool audience
it is a cool audience got to get to some
night markets so I don't know if you
knew this but I so I've spent time all
over East Asia have loved my time in in
Japan in various parts of China I've
spent time in Taiwan most recently in
Korea which completely blew my mind
loved loved loved Soul which is is where
I spent the time but I spent with
respect to taiw on specifically two
summers in Taiwan no way yeah I spent
two summers this is way before Tech made
anything easy because this would have
been like
98 99 maybe in that range somewhere
around there maybe 97 actually and
hilarious story I remember going on
these really rough bulletin boards where
English was like physical or like online
online bul boards and the the English
was not always super straightforward or
easy to understand I was doing my best
and I ended up having someone because I
was trying to find a cheap place to stay
in taipe and couldn't quite figure it
out didn't have any money really so I
ended up connecting with someone who
said they could organize a home stay and
then I arrived in taipe it's pouring
rain I don't know a soul I eventually
take a taxi from the airport torrential
downpour to this supposed Homestay and
it's like a dilapidated church and
they're like here's your bed and it's
just a wooden surface like it's wow a
tabletop and I was like this is where
your back got messed up yeah I was like
oh boy I had this this woman at one
point I was clearly lost approached me
on the street and offer to help me which
I've just due due to a host of reasons I
was wary of I was like uh I'm not sure
if I want like it just seems uncommon
here for this to be viable
offer without strings attached turned
out to be a a Good Samaritan she owned
two restaurants in taipe she was like
you know what I come by anytime
introduce me to all of her friends so I
ended up just getting adopted by this
woman and her basically like ratat
restaurant family it's amazing and
people are fundamentally good remember
you know I am leaning I do lean I wish I
had less of this on the Hoban side so
you're a good influence on me balance
each other yeah yeah in this case
absolutely delivered on on that premise
and just had the best time and and
Taiwan has these fantastic night markets
at the time it was perfect for me
because I such a night owl and like very
late night cultur you you'll go out to
dinners you see this in places like
Argentina too some places in Europe
where you're like this is bizarre it is
11:00 at night and there's an entire
family out with even little kids having
dinner I love that this doesn't make any
sense absolutely loved it had a had had
a wonderful time and that was a long
time ago now I mean I'm trying to you
know running running the basic math here
it's like 20 30 years ago I mean a long
time ago for that reason and many more
also that we haven't taken a trip
together internationally wow like a like
a real trip right we've we've collided
in various places in Italy briefly like
boom like a little a little coarse
Collision although actually you know I
take it back Antarctica that was a real
Tri oh yeah that's a real Tri that was
our last podcast that was a pretty
deliberate Tri that was a long one too
that was a long one 2 weeks about two
weeks and like um not I mean exploration
yes but with lots of constraints right
like don't wander off random wand don't
wander off and fall into a one kmet like
crass and die don't do that all right so
so word Camp Asia what were the dates on
that again roughly is March 7th to 99th
yeah Tim's going to be speaking so
that's that's exciting love how I keep
saying I need to finesse in the details
but Matt is committing on my behalf I am
I I would like to make it happen I
really this is a priority so that is in
there what else are you excited about it
kind of ties into that all right there
something I haven't told you which is I
am taking a sabatical in 2024 sabatical
yeah so automatic has this benefit where
every 5 years you get 2 to three months
fully paid time off okay and a hack on
it to encourage people to take it is if
you don't take it until year 7 you don't
get another one until year 12 the clock
start starts when you come back from the
previous one I extol the benefits of
this we had literally like hundreds and
hundreds of people take them maybe over
a thousand at this point I talk about
why it's so amazing I'm the biggest
hypocrite in 18 years I've not taken one
myself luckily almost every other
executive has so like the example gets
set but I finally was like you know I
just need to pull the trigger and so
February March April including during
this word Camp is I'm going to be
officially on sabatical and so that I'm
honestly
terrified I don't know how to unplug for
that I mean you saw me in Antarctica I
got weird after like eight days in no
internet a lot of people get weird in
Antarctica In fairness yeah so I'm going
to try to do some detox maybe some
silent Retreats you know working on
Hobbies chess sailing ping pong just
just fun unplug stuff but honestly I'm
kind of scared too so I've got one or
two dates that are in there for surgery
you know this this work camp but I'm I'm
just going to show up like a attendee
like guess like I'll speak or something
but like I'm not going to like help plan
it or do anything like that so even
we're going to have a board meeting in
there and it's going to be a good
practice talked about this with the team
like what we going to do about this it's
like well I'll go to the board meeting
but I'll go to it like a board m not
like not like someone who planned out
the agenda and everything like that so
I'll get the material when the other
board members get it versus you know the
multi-week period you know planning
process and everything I would imagine
you're generally a fairly important
quarterback SL
uh primary actor in board meetings so
who is going to be presenting this
information instead of instead of Matt
leaders in the company leaders in the
company yeah our Chief Financial Officer
general counsel are always really big in
the board meetings so here's a question
for you I'm very excited about this and
I'm very skeptical because you've
already mentioned a number of things
that are in there busy things that
you've allowed to slide in with some
semblance of I'm just an observer two
things two things yeah and it's
partially I guess I could I could skip
the board meeting I'm kind of curious
though for this experience yeah so it's
driven right now by curiosity so the
benefit you know a lot of people think
obviously the benefits to the person you
get the 3 months pay time off so that's
pretty cool we now have people who've
done multiple you because they've been
an automatic 10 or 15 years and like
some of the testimonials are amazing
like someone was like yeah I get to take
a summer with my kids and like I think
they're doing their second or third one
they're like this is the last one
because after this they're going to be
in college I'll never get this amount of
time with them probably again for a long
time but there's also a benefit to the
organization it's funny one thing people
ask is they say well do people just take
these and never come back M that's
basically never happened think we've had
people resign like maybe once or twice
out of the like thousand but like it's
very rare two if someone's out for like
2 weeks weeks or 3 weeks you just wait
for them to come back you don't actually
look at the systems at to which they are
in the critical path for 100% agreed
when it's two or three months the
organization needs to figure out how to
work without that person and so it's a
great opportunity to identify those
bottlenecks actually some Financial
Service firms require this for auditing
reasons because if someone's in a
critical path of some Financial thing
it's actually a good practice for to
have someone else do that for a while
that's not really our primary concern
but it is you can figure out your bus
count right pretty quickly it's like oh
wait a second where it also gives great
leadership opportunities so this was
inspired by the former CEO of automatic
Tony Schneider who just did this cuz
he's cool and he did like a three-month
road trip with his family at the time he
was CEO I was president and it was gave
me an opportunity to practice being the
CEO and we saw what worked well and what
didn't and then like also LED like oh we
need to do this executive hire because
Tony's really good at something and I'm
not so we need to hire someone to fill
that in and like so these are part of
the reasons I think it's awesome for
organizations first thought if you had a
thousand people do spacal or however
many people but a lot of people do it
last I checked you guys are involved in
the content business have you thought of
or has anyone
assembled anywhere sabatical best
practices because this is
also on some level synonymous with what
I described in the 4our work week is the
Min retirement yeah a primary value of
which is you establish systems and
stress test systems and processes that
outlive this medical right they persist
is this something you guys have gathered
is there a is there some type of
discussion form where you have anything
like this it's so funny because as of
today no but probably by the time get
this gets published at automatic.com
shabaa we started working on a page so a
lot of people blog their experience this
is a page that other people meaning the
public yeah it would be just SL
sabatical so a lot of people blog about
their experience and there's really all
types some people like have walked the
El Camino for a couple months or done
like the Pacific coast Crush thing some
people just stay at home and chill out
you know some like it's really it's all
over the map and I don't think there's a
right way to do it except hopefully not
just do what you were doing before and
we do kind of really strongly encourage
people unplug actually someone just
who's on sabatical pinked me on slack
and I was like don't make me turn off
your
access you need someone you need someone
to do that for you you need to hire a
police officer at the end of the
sabatical I put a child lock on my phone
or something and like I'll give you the
Cod a cookie jar with a timer on it yeah
the end of the sabatical the sticle was
a huge
success why has it been a huge success
because there's doing it to say look I'm
walking the walk and I did my sabatical
but that's not very interesting right in
and of itself it's like okay fine it is
good to be consistent it's good to be
consistent but you could also kind of
creep off to your laptop and yeah and in
theory be on sabatical but in practice
be a lurker on all sorts of different
business calls and meetings that would
that would be pretty terrible um it
would be so what would success look like
and actually something I'm debating is
cuz you know I do love coding and
computer stuff and so like playing
around with like LED programming or
something is maybe a sabatical project
but I'm also like I'm on the computer
all day so just for like a health reason
I think I should really get off so
what's success it's kind of what we
talked about for the organization should
come back a lot stronger and people
should get a lot more robust what's
sucess for you I'm most interested in
Matt Mullen I think for me is that I'm
recharged you know a lot of people you
know the funny thing is people come back
really wanting to work and that typical
thing I hear is like kind of takes a
month to unplug for your brain to like
reset month two you just enjoy things
like month three people start to get
antsy to return mhm M which is I don't
know if that will happen to me but
that's a pretty common Ark so I hope I
come back with Like A Renewed Energy to
be honest this last kind of two years
has been really really hard mhm you know
we had lots of business ups and downs
you know svb was a sh there's been all
sorts of crazy stuff AI stuff and I am a
little toasty to be honest like not
burnt out but like definitely at times
like a little more stressed to normal
where it's really me and you always talk
about how I'm so calm like thank you but
also like you know I'm human too so it
gets to me the duck on the pond so
kicking like hell
underneath so I think that's the thing
I'm looking forward to what am I scared
of there's a weird thing we're also
being scared like of like people not
needing you or irrelevance mhm which I
think is like a really core fear for me
mhm it's not maybe not practical and
automatic but like it there's something
there is the needing you and relevance
are those the same in your mind or those
different things they're probably
different versions like relevance is
maybe in a global context or in the
company context and needing you is maybe
even maybe like interpersonal you know
and so like when I've done like some
meditations or some other work like that
can be like a core fear of mine and then
then maybe how have I designed
organizations to need me yeah in a way
that's not healthy that's one of the
questions I ask myself or you know if
you're always if you get a lot of
benefit and I do sometimes like you came
in and saved the thing mhm that feels
really nice especially in like a CEO job
or a job which is very morphous people
are like what do you actually do like oh
I saved the thing you know but then are
you hiring people that need saving a lot
or you like you know what's the sort of
like Shadow side of that Jerry Colona
who I think you've had on right oh yeah
absolutely is he's he's we had a great
episode he has some very good questions
he has some very good questions my
favorite is how am I complicit
creating the conditions I say I don't
want such a good question it's one of
the best ones yeah so I think success
for me is also yeah just come back
really energized excited hopefully with
a lot of inspiration and ideas because I
get a lot of inspiration from like art
or stuff outside of Wordpress recharged
I mean there are different ways one can
use that word right so are we talking
about I I would imagine we're talking
about recharge physically intellectually
Etc multiple levels definitely want to
dial on health stuff what would that
potentially look like getting that
outside forcing him to do a two- mile
jog I think that he actually has to
train for sunlight nature nothing novel
this is all like the basic stuff you
talk about basics of the basics for a
reason yeah and and it's so effective
I'll probably experiment with some stuff
you know they just started to be this
blueprint delivery service in San
Francisco I don't know what that is oh
Brian Johnson yeah has a blueprint
system you know there's like the the
weird food that's like a gel or
something like um yeah there's now
delivery service for that so like you
get your soilent grain in a bottle and
I'm actually pretty excited about it it
looks like prettyy try it out I'm not
really going to cook this stuff so yeah
just do some experiments there so I
asked you what success might look like
yeah made some Headway there I can ask a
million follow-ups but I'm going to ask
a different question it's looking at the
sabatical from perhaps the opposite side
which is let's say after the sabatical
you or maybe just the people closest to
you are like yeah sabatical didn't
really work
kind of failed kind of fell on its face
what are the what do you think are the
most likely Temptations or slipping
points or
issues that could
compromise the sabatical well somehow my
health got worse over it yeah sure right
so like a lot of the things we've talked
about and where I find a lot of joy and
happiness is typically in being
generative making things not consuming
things yeah but I think it's very easy
to fall into a consumption like like a
henis treadmill type thing and it's nice
sometimes I mean about to the holidays
like I'll definitely consume some stuff
or it's nice take a nice meal on
vacation but if that becomes your all
the time we've seen that happen to
friends who've been successful and
typically does not look great yeah the
brief history of the world guy the
amazing historian has a great quote
about that oh you're thinking about will
Durant yeah
Durant I'm going to read it actually
okay while you're looking that up I'll
just say I'm interested in what
Temptations cuz I could name mine like
what Temptations you think you need to
be
preemptively guarding against because
mhm the siren song is likely to H pull
you how might you be complicit in
creating the conditions yeah social
media that can need to be careful about
that particularly my Twitter X addiction
news consumption mhm things my most
dangerous is where something is
sometimes productive or has some
positive but is probably net negative on
a whole or if I spend too many hours on
it mhm phone time in general I'd love to
get down screen time in general yeah do
you think you could just take your
entire sabatical off of social media
just delete them all from your phone not
use them at all be interesting I mean
they'd still be there when you came back
yeah you know enough people if you
really really I want to get on the phone
while I'm walking outside in the sun and
talk to someone like cyan or run and
just be like hey would you mind just
giving me like the can you Twitter to me
the most exciting things going on right
now in your field and I'll trade because
I'm excited to share blah blah blah like
you can do that that's a good idea I'm
sure you could do that I like these
ideas keep them coming um will Durant
this is from fallen leaves which is that
post humus book Health lies in action
and so it Graces youth to be busy is the
secret of Grace and half the secret of
content let us ask the Gods Not for
possessions but for things to do
happiness is in making things rather
than in consuming them that is amazing
isn't that beautiful that is can you
send that to me please yeah all right
will Durant you know will Durant I mean
just the is it will and Ariel I want to
say so
prolific and
also so incredibly good at crafting Pros
a man yeah did you read the fallen
leaves book no I haven't it's neat it's
on life right so it's kind of his and I
guess it was discovered after he passed
like the manuscript wow and so like many
years like 30 years after he passed or
something incredible so that's uh as
we're I'm calling it The
semantical Matt is a specialist in dad
jokes this began I mean it may have
become in the delivery room for all I
know okay let's let's we may come back
I'm sure with dinner we'll talk about
the the sabatical more but in terms of
things that you've changed your mind on
are excited about or absurd things you
do m any and all of the above you want
to do a lightning round yeah I've got
some changed and I've got some absurd
okay changed changed my mind on nuclear
actually okay from what to what well I
think I think even like when I was a
baby my mom took me to like a nuclear
protest or something and so like as
someone caring about the environment I
sort of assumed nuclear was
not I was kind of anti-nuclear M right
chable Etc and now I'm pretty fully
convinced that is necessary we should be
building as many of these plants as
possible and it's like going to be an
amazing part of the bridge to like yeah
more carbon free future mhm and you see
that in small scale reactors with with
less likelihood
of technical problems and and issues
that yeah all of the above yeah let's
take the things that work they're
expensive like we need to get better at
building stuff like China is really
kicking our butt here you stop turning
ones off that we're running so like that
sort of stuff like stop shooting
ourselves in the foot saw what happened
with Germany you know when they turn a
bunch of stuff off but then now turning
it back on so this is going the right
way and there's a lot of investment in
the tech here and so you know let the
Bill Gates start up and the other ones
and the Sam Alman start up like let them
ship and nuclear in this case refers to
fision we're talking about fision yes
and there could be breakthroughs around
other things but I mean people are
scared of this but also like the US
military has nuclear powered submarines
and C carriers that are going around
underwater like we've been done this
very reliably for like many decades now
so I feel like that was a wrong turn in
history mhm some theories it might have
been influenced actually by like
countries or companies with a lot of
sort of fossil fuel but you know
sometimes we do the wrong thing then we
figure it out so nuclear is one of them
psychedelics tell me you know thanks to
you we're very early supporters of a lot
of research around this you supported a
lot of amazing things and I felt like
especially during that period where
everything was outlawed in very Pro
legalization in a lot of ways and like
for weed for example I think there's
some interesting stuff coming out around
like marijuana which I kind of not heard
any bad stuff about where like oh this
can actually create some risk for
psychosis there's I used to make fun of
these things right like the the old
documentaries were like you smoke one
blunt you go crazy re re Madness re for
madness like all this stuff it was so
dumb but we funded a lot of research
and I like that people are researching
these things so we can understand the
good and the bad of these molecules how
to use them safely we see the impact so
incredible mhm and there's also I I have
now seen I think you have as well where
it can go wrong mhm super rare but
there's other stuff maybe confounding
factors so yeah for sure so that's a
changed your mind on or yeah I think I
used to be like very super pro just open
legalization of everything like you're
18 or above or 21 or above you can just
get it at any store whatever you want
whenever you want yeah now questioning
that yeah I think here's your thoughts
there I you've always been pretty
cautious when you talk about it publicly
yeah I'm cautious I'm cautious when I
talk about it privately too I mean I
would say that net net if you were to
talk to say my ex-girlfriends I talk
more people out of psychedelics than I
talk into by a very wide margin I'd say
like eight or nine out of 10 would be a
case of dissuasion and not persuasion
there are a few reasons for that one
is if someone is looking for a quick fix
and by the nature of their questions and
requests it is clear to me they're not
going to do they're almost certainly not
going to do any
preparation or integration afterwards
which you could compare I mean I often
compare to say serious knee surgery or
shoulder replacement surgery whereby
you're going to do a lot of due
diligence you're going to do probably
strengthening and and a number of
prehab exercises diligently for a period
of time to prepare your body for the
surgery you undergo the surgery which is
very tightly
supervised then you do rehab and these
are all critical components of the
therapeutic outcome and I think ghoul
Dolan as an example who's been on the
podcast and the potential for reopening
critical Windows is a compelling new
Theory SL hypothesis around some of the
amazing outcomes that you see with these
conditions like complex PTSD and so on
where somebody has the diagnosis of PTSD
for 17 years they failed every
intervention and then at the end of a
trial you have something like I'm
pulling this number out of the air but
it's not that far off like 67% full
remission where the best other
alternative is like 15% or something not
even close they're just universes apart
but the the importance of the weeks
following an experience as one example
so if somebody comes to me and it's
clear to me that they're like What's the
Silver Bullet give it to be an index
card I'm not going to read any books I'm
not I don't have time for ABC dur e but
I do have 15 minutes should I do 5 DMT
I'm like absolutely not no you shouldn't
well and so many of these things are XYZ
assisted therapy right and so the
assisted therapy part is is really great
I would say
furthermore there is a there has been
historically and by historically I mean
recent history in the last say 10 years
where the
conversation and conversations around
psychedelics have changed quite
dramatically there's a lot more research
there are many for-profit companies now
at this point which which is fantastic
on a bunch of levels and also
incredibly adds a degree of complexity
from an intellectual property
and let's just call it open source
perspective that on some levels can be
concerning I see both sides of this cuz
I'm actually I want some new molecules
yeah I'm fine can they engineer
something that maybe doesn't have some
of the downsides I am all for novel
Innovation but people should not be
rewarded with patn that can be used to
potentially restrict manufactur of
related compounds if they are not
producing something that is truly novel
with some utility that's my perspective
if if we're talking about well we can
certainly get into this but there is a
there is a role for new molecules of
course there is right and if you could
take for instance something like LSD and
modify it it's slightly such that it is
more of what people might call a psychop
plasencio effect but it can be used in
an outpatient setting for something like
cluster headaches maybe shorter yeah
fantastic right I do have we could talk
about this for hours um I do think the
we were talking about Munger and Buffett
earlier right never ask a barber if you
need a haircut I think it's very
important to consider the incentives
involved when you are looking at the
suggested protocols from a for-profit
company I invest in for-profit companies
all the time I'm clearly pro market
driven Solutions on a million different
levels and if someone is incentivized to
shoehorn therapy within currently
existing
Frameworks and for that reason and many
others including let's just say rate of
turnover or volume of patients they're
pushing for an experience that is 10 to
15 minutes in length in Earth time I
have a lot of questions to ask before I
would endorse
something like that but suffice to say
the conversation has been heavily biased
towards positive stories and I think
maybe overly so people who went through
the winter are like hey let's not easy
does it and I think I I kind of fell for
that a little bit yeah there's a there's
a huge survivorship bias I think that's
going to change but especially with
smaller numbers and when for good reason
people feel like they are part of let's
just say in the last 10 years so 2015 a
lot is starting to happen in the very
early stages like the Hopkins Center and
so
on people feel like they are part of a
movement and they want this movement to
succeed and there are certain Milestones
that are incredibly important and
potential inflection points for opening
up these therapies to eventually
millions of people and they don't want
to do anything to jeopardize that so if
there is a story for instance of someone
on the Underground who in a soloc cybin
assisted session even though they have
no outstanding pre-existing issues
outside of say hypertension has a heart
attack and dice in session that is not
going to make it to the radio waves
generally speaking and there are
examples of this even though something
like psilocybin is not there's no known
ld50 in terms of lethal dose 50 that
would kill say 50% of a a random
sampling of thousand people so
physiologically it's very well tolerated
but these experiences can be very
intense and they're not well suited to
all people nor all conditions let's just
take schizophrenia as an example it's
just enough people do anything like
people die at Disney world every day
yeah right right yeah it's also a case
where if up to this point you've by and
large outside of an IND outside of an
indigenous context because really in the
United States by and large we're not
contending with that with the exception
of perhaps pay to use in the Native
American church and so on but if we're
looking at more Western informed
facilitated sessions using these various
classical psychedelics you're looking at
the sample size to date tens of
thousands of people probably who have
done that's generous gu generous who
have done guided sessions typically at
high cost mhm often White Glove service
let's just call it that is not going to
be the experience of the average person
if they're going through Kaiser
Permanente or someone else to get mdm's
Psychotherapy 5 years from now and when
you go from 10,000 to 20 to
100,000 shit's going to happen that's
just that's just the the the fact of the
matter you certainly see this with any
drug that makes it through phase three
and then ends up shipping millions of
pills like you discover a lot in the
process of doing that and there are
interactions and contraindications that
would be very hard to predict until
things are in the wild so to speak I'm
on the same page with you in the sense
that I'm I really feel with these tools
you mentioned nuclear I mean our our
friend who rest in peace Roland
Griffiths used to say that you're
working with nuclear power like you're
working with psychological nuclear power
when you're using psychedelic compounds
you need to be incredibly thoughtful
it's a good analogy yeah right it can be
radioactive it can be healing
chemotherapy and it can also be very
harmful absolutely and it can be
generative or it can be destructive and
plasticity in and of itself this word
gets used
often in a lay discussion as a net
positive but plasticity isn't
automatically a positive thing it
depends a lot on what transpires in that
window of plasticity that was my big
fear I'm like hey I like my mind I like
my life I don't want to like stir
anything up or like not sure I want to
throw that Playdoh in the microwave
right so that's a lot of my particularly
successful friends like their
nervousness around it yeah and seen huge
like positive impacts on many many
people so yeah and I think with with
many of these things and another reason
I I tend to dissuade folks often is if
it's just
curiosity well it's kind of like I'm
just curious should I go into the
reactor and play with some rods I'm like
if you were to then ask is this risky
I'd say compared to what okay compared
to not satisfying that Curiosity yeah
it's risky if you were to say
because for instance in the context of
psychedelics let's just say I began
specifically which is very interesting
wow you took it there no I did well
because it has known cardiac risk and
people can die using Ian unlike some of
these more better known classical
psychedelics where there's there's very
low documented physiological risk Iain
is risky let's just say if you're a
psychedelic tourist and you're like I
just want to try a bunch of stuff right
is it risky yes compared to not doing it
if on the other hand though you're
talking to someone who is a heroin
addict who's living on the streets who's
at risk of suicide or or overdose or
fill in the
blank it's a question of comparison in
which case I think it's an incredibly
promising Avenue Worth exploring and
there are ways to mitigate some of that
risk Dr Nolan Williams is doing it could
be a shot out of there a lot uh kind of
brings me to my next changed mind thing
which is perhaps the antidote to some of
this which is breath work all right so I
I think I
thought breath work was just kind of
whatever Dum and there's a million
versions of it right and there's apps
for like other ship there's the Wim Hoff
stuff there's all these sorts of
different things I also like we had a
friend from like estland who's like oh
yeah all the hippies who like did a ton
of stuff in the 70s don't actually take
stuff anymore they just do breath work
now and so some these things came in
from different areas I've just started
to explore it a lot more MH it's
incredibly powerful we've been playing
with a shift wave chair right kind of
coordinates the pules on the chair with
breath work the breath work is I would
say a lot of the benefit of that it's
also a tool you can have with you at all
times MH you can travel to any country
in the world with it like it's like with
your lungs it's literally the most basic
element of living is breath and so
there's something cool if that's perhaps
to unlock to a more calm inner state or
like access to different things what is
been your personal experience with
breath work I feel like there's breath
work that can make me sleepy I feel like
there's breath breath work that like
helps me Focus I feel like this breath
work it's the Tony Robins thing you do
like this like there's stuff to like
give you energy particularly I'm very
interested in endogenous Solutions
versus ex exogenous exogenous yeah so
instead of like having another green tea
or something if I'm tired in the
afternoon what's a movement of breath I
could do something internally yeah so
exogenous easy way to remember that is
like exoskeleton people have heard that
right so outside the body doing
something using something outside the
body
endoskeleton well yeah endoskeleton is
probably what we have I guess although
you don't really we just call it a
skeleton I would second that and say
that breath work is something I would
view as also a prerequisite even if your
intention is to say ultimately use
psychedelics uh I will very often chat
with friends who are interested in
exploring many of these different tools
and I say okay first thing you do is
you're going to do 30 days of the the
introductory course on the waking up app
from Sam Harris so good you're going to
combine that with reading awareness by
Anthony
Dello and after the second week or after
the after four weeks you're going to do
a holotropic breath work course because
it's there are a lot of facilitators and
it's a a term that is relatively turning
towards wholeness is what that means by
the way which is
relatively easy to find in most
metropolitan areas and it was developed
by Stannis sloff gra and others and you
should do at least a weekend course with
whole Tri of breath work ideally do two
or three separate sessions so that you
have a chance to have a breadth of
different experience including maybe
some challenging or strange or
disorienting experiences mhm and then we
can talk about potentially phase two or
three if you even need to go there and a
few things happen it's a good course
just for anyone to follow exactly what
happens in many cases is people are like
this is fantastic I'm going to continue
meditating and the breath work has has
shown me that I don't need to go to an
extreme altered state and I actually
feel so much better thank you so much
and that's not the end of the journey
but it's a set of tools that they then
take forth without in any way escalating
things it's always with you yeah it also
is just a proof of concept I think for
me that if if you are going to throw the
Playdoh in the microwave with nuclear
power in this case AKA Psych Al if
you're not willing to do 4 weeks of
things that will benefit you anyway you
shouldn't throw your Playdoh in the
microwave because there's a chance that
something goes sideways or that you get
destabilized and it requires some really
concerted effort with support staff some
type of safety net to you know put
Humpty Dumpty back together again and if
you have not demonstrated the
willingness and capability to do that on
the front end I have zero confidence
that you will be able to do that on the
tail end what would you recommend for
someone going through a deep depression
cuz one of the things about depression
it can be hard to take a shower to do
that you know 30 days of the thing so do
you have like breakouts or things you
recommend to interrupt that cycle
depression depression is a multifaceted
beast and for people who don't have the
context I for my entire adult life
certain
although the frequency and severity has
changed substantially in the last 10
years had extend experienced extensive
extended and extensive depressive
episodes almost killed myself in college
I've written about that at some length
so if you just
search Tim Ferris suicide that post will
pop up it's one of the more important
posts I've ever written it would be
certainly top three or so of the blog
posts I've written very proud of that
post I mean if you look at the comments
you'll see why thousands of comments at
this point but how I relate to suicidal
ideation I think can be found in that
post but number one I'm not a doctor I
don't play one on the internet but I do
have a lot of personal experience
depression and I've been approached by a
lot of people with depression including
close friends and I would say that as
you mentioned it can be seemingly
impossible to summon the will to do
anything when you're severely depressed
I mean there there are people who get
almost into Catatonia right I actually
so this year I experienced it for the
first time no kidding a very close loved
one was going through chemotherapy MH
and it was interesting it hit me quite
hard which felt dumb as well cuz I'm not
going through it myself but what really
like woke me up is like usually you hear
me talk about WordPress automatic I'm so
excited about it there was a day I just
looked at my computer I was like wow I
don't care about this mhm that never
happened before yeah was the wake up I
was like oh man like everything seems
kind of grayscale I feel this apathy and
it really gave me a lot of empathy for
things you've described before that I
had an experience personally what helped
you I don't know if my example is good
cuz I do want to know your
answer I will give you my answer for me
some of the external conditions changing
so the chemo getting better and better
and ending was part of it that's not a
great answer cuz sometimes your external
conditions still suck or bad things
happen you can lose loved ones I got
really strict about like exercise I cut
out all alcohol like like okay I just
need to like detox clean up mhm like be
like kind of Monk mode yeah and I think
that's all I know how to do sleep you
know try to like I probably uninstalled
Twitter at that point yeah like it was
just really like it's kind of things
that are on my list anyway but you know
dayto day I would say I try to hit a lot
of these things and I'm casual about
some yeah so I'll make couple of
recommendations I I I'm very cautious
about making broad prescriptions because
there's so many different varieties
right there is everything ranging from
I'm having a couple of tough weeks and
I'm not sure why but I can still
function really well I'm high
functioning all the way to I'm I want to
hang myself tomorrow yeah and those are
those are entirely different species
closer to that first one for me yeah
experience yeah a couple of resources I
want to recommend first of all if if
you're suicidal certainly please call a
hotline and I've been through this
you're not alone a lot of people face
this and even though it feels like it's
permanent it's personal there's nothing
you can do to change it there are tools
and I'm living proof of that so I mean I
am incredibly happy and fulfilled right
now and I've I've found tools that help
to stabilize and and facilitate that not
100% of the time because I'm still part
of The Human Experience so I would just
say you're not Al Al and if if it's an
acute experience please call Suicide
Hotline and I'll put that in the show
notes but if you search my name Tim
Ferris suicide that post has helped a
lot of people there's also a post I
wrote called something along the lines
of productivity hacks for the manic
depressive neurotic and something rather
like
me which has been helpful for a lot of
folks and that that also I think just
allows people to remove some of the
Judgment the self judgment from The
Experience because there's the
experience that is difficult and then
there's the harsh self judgment that
sometimes that companies in that was
tough for me right where you might you
might all you might be in a really
challenging State you're suffering and
then you have this voice that says who
the are you kidding are you joking
right now like your life is great
there's so many people who have so many
more challenges than you like you don't
even have the right to feel this way
like suck it up buttercup get it
together and variations of that and it
makes it a lot worse so that post I just
mentioned which I'll link to in the show
notes has helped some people with that
you know lastly I would say if it's
really acute there are a few tools that
I'm hesitant to recommend because there
are especially in the first some risks
Associated I did a podcast with Dr John
Crystal who's the chair of Psychiatry
Yale which was effectively in
everything you would ever want to know
about ketamine episode and think for
acute suicidal ideation and risk of self
harm intravenous or IM IM ketamine is
very interesting is a pattern
interrupt that episode is available for
folks there are risks associated with
ketamine there is addiction potential uh
it is it is something to keep an eye on
but again risky compared to what if
someone's at risk of cute self harm then
it's it's generally well tolerated
meaning it doesn't suppress respiration
it is very well
researched and that is that is one tool
another that is a newer tool that I've
been exploring myself also which we
might talk about at dinner because we
haven't talked about it is something
called accelerated TMS and this
is transcranial magnetic stimulation
various types of brain stimulation for
addressing treatment resistant
depression and anxiety there are some
newer protocols like the saint protocol
which was developed at Stanford that are
incredibly interesting and way faster
too cuz the old treatments would take
like 30 days an hour a day or something
like that the new ones are way faster
way faster so you're taking treatments
that would otherwise take a month or two
and compressing it into five days wow
and fascinating fascinating cut Cutting
Edge stuff that I'm paying a lot of
attention to because some of the results
are equal to or even greater than with
durability so if as fast acting and as
durable or to a greater extent fast
acting and durable than some of the
Psychedelic assist therapies about it as
well cuz we have friends that won't ever
take a psychedelic or some of these
things or there actually this whole
religions Mormons LDS Etc so some of the
stuff I think is like really cool
accessibility kind of like the same way
breath work can be absolutely and for
people who might be older a little a
little frail or with different
conditions higher blood pressure Etc a
lot of these folks should not touch
psychedelics they just should not the
risk profile doesn't make sense and that
would also be true for certain types of
disorders I mean later research May
overturn this but for the time being say
schizophrenia borderline personality
disorder a lot of folks who maybe lean
more towards the this is not a medical
term but like
chaotic or like entropic disorders
versus Hyper rigidity disorders like OCD
I would consider chronic anxiety and
depression to be also rigidity issues on
some level because they are often
thought Loops things that repeat right
there is a stuckness whereas something
like schizophrenia which I I have um
seen up close and personal has a
different feeling to it uh it's just
it's an opposite end of the Spectrum in
some respects uh so I'm very interested
in those conditions if I'll check out
those Post Yeah for someone who's like
having a hard couple of weeks I you you
mentioned Tony Robbins earlier I I will
mention something that I learned from
him I don't know if he's the original
source of this but I used to put this at
the top of my journals I would I would
write it out at the top of my journal so
that I would see it every morning and it
was basically a let's call it a
flowchart that's an overstatement and it
said state in all caps with an with an
arrow that went to story and then that
went to strategy so State story
strategy and what that's meant to say is
what happens to many people who are
depressed or anxious or whatever is they
sit down and they try to figure out how
to fix the thing they go straight to
strategy like what should I do the
challenge there is that if you're
looking at the world
through gray glasses the story that
you're going to come up with is going to
be most likely a disabling story and
then you're going to come up with
strategies that are by and large pretty
ineffective
H if on the other hand you start with
state so if you're in a low energy State
you hop in a cold shower for 5 minutes
or you
do 50 jumping jacks or you do 20
push-ups anything to change your state
from a low energy state to a higher
energy State and that's governed by all
sorts of things but let's keep it simple
so low to higher energy State then you
sit down and you're able to because of
changes in neurotransmitters or any
number of things you have a more
enabling story right so you've turned
the gray maybe a tint or two brighter
then the strategies you come up with are
going to be more effective so just
reminding myself constantly before you
jump to the strategy like the what to do
the how to fix have you addressed the
state because this thing in between the
story really matters because if your
narrative is like oh I'm always
pessimistic I've never been able to fix
this you're starting at a deficit right
you have severe handicap and coming up
with approaches that are going to to
help you so that might be helpful to
people as well like State story strategy
that is the order I I got to give credit
to my mom too she gave me a list of
three things that I found really helpful
she was like did you sleep mhm are
drinking water mhm so sleep water and
then you've been in
nature it's a good checklist I like that
cuz it's 3 and so sometimes I just do
like a check and be like ah man this
morning is so tough I felt like I wasn't
great in that meeting and then I'll just
I can run that yeah sometimes the body
scan I also ask myself like am I hry
yeah you know the basics right our body
kind of emotions come from our our
system and sometimes like it's saying
I'm hungry I'm hungry and it's coming
through as like something else our brain
interprets it so yeah totally and to
invoke our mutual friend Kevin Kelly in
his book of excellent advice which came
out not too long ago great book great
piy and one of them is if if you don't
know what you need chances are it's
sleep and or if you don't know what to
do chances are you need more sleep and
if you're in a depressed state and this
is something I have to remind myself of
I would be inclined even subconsciously
to consume stimulants because that does
change your
state but if you consume stimulants and
then that disrupts your sleep
architecture and then maybe you drink a
little booze to take the edge off
because you're trying to get to sleep
this is is a vicious
cycle and you know I I had U Richard
Branson on the podcast years ago and his
advice was sto drinking like as far as
depression goes he was just like in nine
out of 10 cases alcohol is somehow in
that picture in his lived experience in
his Social Circles so those are a few
things that that come to mind there are
other things certainly I mean I could I
could go on and on I think the work by
Byron ktie and doing turnarounds
interrogating your beliefs m is very
valuable so if you have a belief
that I'm making this up but my sister is
selfish and always does what she
wants there are many work pages and
exercises that are available for free on
Byron Katie's website so if you just
search Byron KY b y r o n KD K tie the
work you'll find the website all sorts
of PDFs you can you can you can take
down but let's just say my sister's
selfish she only does does what she
wants you would then create alternative
sentences and find supporting evidence
for each one so my sister isn't selfish
she never does what she wants and you
have to come up with some
examples you might also replace it with
like I'm selfish I always do what I want
and then you come up with some
examples
and I and others have found these
exercises to be incredibly powerful
there are a million in one different
varieties of this for me the turnarounds
where you have to come up with
confirming evidence for statements that
were not your starting statement I find
defangs your beliefs which are thoughts
we take to be true I that a lot take
back to Charlie Munger he says you
should be able to argue the opposite
yeah just as well as you can argue your
case yeah you get thrown on stage you
got to be Banky like yeah yeah useful
exercise right really useful exercise
got a couple more let's do it I saw the
most incredible horrifying stat which
made me change my mind on Tik Tok oh I'm
just going to read this cuz it was
ridiculous 20% of 18 to 29 year olds did
you hear this no and said do you agree
with the statement the Holocaust was a
myth wow agreed with it and they had the
chart of the different erors and like 65
plus it was like 0% yeah yeah or like
0.1 or something and then like it goes
up to this 18 to 29 20% that's
horrifying like oh my goodness whatever
has led to that sort of misinformation
mhm and there's some indicators that it
could be sort of Tik Tok related makes
me really question like is this an
adversarial thing like is this another
country like goosing the algorithm a
little bit yeah in a way that yeah is
very scary misinformation that's
terrifying yeah I mean you
imagine what a geopolitical Advantage it
would be to be able to ever so slightly
nudge sentiment about X or person Y in a
certain direction our social networks
are not allowed in China yeah there's no
Facebook there's no Twitter X there's no
like I don't there's no Instagram I
think that's there's a reason for that
MH so I think if You' asked me earlier
this year or something I would have been
like whatever we're free Society we
should have everything like that's dumb
you know Trump tried to get rid of it I
was like oh you know yeah now I'm like
huh and it was that stat that kind of
like blew my mind got some absurd things
M blogging I think is absurd and it's
beautiful absurd meaning it's like a
like the the horse and buggy in the
modern world of of clips and video and
and AI what do you mean it feels that
way sometimes right like everyone's like
on to something else I guess newsletters
are kind of like blogging but like you
know what there's something so beautiful
about doing it I've been doing a lot
more this year and it's one of the most
rewarding things of my year what do you
find rewarding about
the comments the interaction followup so
it's all that the writing well the act
of writing forces you to clarify your
thinking it activates something
different in your brain I mean you know
this I'm preaching to a writer a real
writer that's incredible Act of
publishing is incredibly vulnerable
scary and then all the stuff that
happens afterwards you learn so much
from yeah we need to chat
about how to not resurrect because
there's still good commenters but how to
how one could create like the best
comment section on the internet because
what I've noticed and I'm sure you've
noticed this is that with blog posts a
lot of that conversation has sort of
left the room to social media so the
volume of comments and so on is less but
there are exceptions right if I if I go
to say the Derek siver's blog and I look
at his comment section amazing comment
section right if I look at Tyler cow's
comment pretty good although mixed
there's a lot of mixed but he's I mean I
remember he moderates it and he
participates himself he moderates I
think that's that's the secret you have
to participate yourself he posed a
question was like the most underrated
Geniuses of all time and he nominated
Beethoven or I'm screwing it up but it
was some classical music composer and
there was an amazing discussion in the
comments which of course may have been
as I think you're implying tightly
curated I don't know I think he's pretty
open and but you set an example yeah so
by the behavior that you do in the
comments and that you know what you
allow that sets the standard and people
follow that yeah also SEO kind of screws
it up because you get people just trying
to get links or so you really have to be
careful about that all right so blogging
I changed my mind oh this is my last
change of mind it's a little happier
than the last one Vienna sausages Vienna
sausages you know the sausages and the
can I have no idea what you're talking
about oh wow so there's this thing
called Vienna sausages um I have no idea
if they're from Vienna but it's like
kind of like um how many six or seven
sausages in like a little can like this
pops open one of those I used to do it
have it as a kid and I you know it makes
me think they're not from vietna I
usually am not allowed to shop for
myself because I I'm basically like a
Gummy Bear kid with a credit card my
parents credit card and like so I bought
a bunch of Vienna sausages cuz I was
like oh this is going to be healthy and
so I brought it home as an adult you're
saying oh this was like last month okay
all right got it cuz I was like I'll put
it in my desk St I like to keep like
healthy snacks by my desk and where I
work mhm and I just assumed it's sausage
must be like you know the punchline
that's coming it's terrible for you you
read the ingredients the sodium the
everything it's like and it's like the
meat is mystery meat like it's so I
really thought I changed my mind on that
and I was I was saying oh yeah I had
healthy lunch from Vienna sausage and
someone was like a very close loved one
was like that's not healthy I was like
yeah it is and like we Googled it and I
was so
wrong so okay so you Vienna sausage
sorry guys you're you're on the
suspended list this is a a fun food one
as well let's do it you know there's so
much good fancy pizza in San Francisco
like flower and water Etc one that I
really like is called Delina uhuh I
another thing perhaps with my Texas
upbringing that I'm obsessed with is the
sauce known as ranch ranch yeah ranch
sauce ranch sauce like ranch dressing
ranch dressing yeah yeah no sauce rch
dress you see this is why you're the
chef
ranch sauce got it okay Ranch I I asked
for Ranch in Delina and they just
scoffed I've not been scoffed like that
in a while and then I tried this
overseas where there was something and I
asked for some ranch and it it did not
go well I will now contrast at a
restaurant called Kessa in San Francisco
a new one Kessa or Kessa La Kessa Kessa
okay and they have a lot of like xay on
people it's a casual restaurant but
really good service they served a
amazing Pizza I had the crust I like the
to dip the crust in the the ranch I was
like do you have any Ranch I was ready
to be disappointed or scoffed at he said
hold on and they actually ran to like
another restaurant next door to get me
some that was amazing but then I
realized cuz like how do you take more
agency in your life I keep asking for
ranch and being shut down like how how
am I creating the conditions I say I
don't want and so I was like oh just get
those packets so I went on Amazon and I
got like 200 Ranch
packets for like $16 or something so
these have now arrived place in San
Francisco and I'm going to it's going to
be my next what's in my bag it's some
pocket Ranch pocket Ranch yeah you just
keep keep one or two in every inside
pocket on your fancy jackets I've seen
I'm so curious what I'm going to put
Ranch on in the future having it
available at all times I still insist on
looking at every Tab and email and I'm
tens of thousands not hundreds of
thousands behind at this point I think I
have 500 tabs open right now wait what
this is an absurd thing yeah yeah yeah
you have 500 tabs open in your browsers
yeah yeah okay and the email thing is
like I I'll even reply to emails from
like seven or eight years ago I have
like that folder of stuff like and I go
through it almost like masochistically
and the sad thing is like on a third of
them it just bounces people don't have
Emil address Earth you replying to
emails from seven or eight years ago is
this just like your Opus day Penance
like there's probably some of that just
cat and Ninetails on the back for I also
like I'm not worthy appreciated people
who have replied to me all right when I
was no body or anything like that and so
I kind of want to pay that for it a
little bit I also just am really
impressed I feel like there may a point
when you've repaid that debt what's that
I said I feel like there may be a point
where you sufficiently repay that debt
that you don't need to continue to crawl
on your knees on broken glass with your
tab of I good idea you asked for absurd
things this is absurd so I'm still doing
that and um yeah maybe I'll work on that
on my sabatical there you go I'll just
answer emails the whole time oh God I'm
kidding I'm kidding um I think you might
have some of this as well I have a very
Ultra critical eye mhm and I've been
constantly remodeling things instead of
just enjoying them they're pretty decent
and fine already and and this is one of
those things that there's a superpower
as well like I can open a web app or a
design and like immediately spot things
down to the pixel the downside is
sometimes I go in like an apartment
that's beautiful I'm like oh next to
that speaker there's like a little divot
in your ceiling I have the same thing
that now you're going to see every time
no yeah I just cursed your apartment but
so that is like a curse as well and I'd
like to be able to turn it off to just
enjoy things as they are the wobby saabi
mhm how do you think you'll make any
progress with that no idea maybe someone
can leave a
com I become a bit better at this there
are there are cases where I succumb to
this fine ey for detail but I think that
and and this comes back to the
depression question a little bit I would
push back on the idea that that some of
the interventions I mentioned like 30
days of meditation are Out Of Reach for
people who are having a hard couple of
weeks I would say that the Returns on
something and this is very simple right
number one the social return on say
going to a weekend transal meditation
training interacting with someone is net
positive to begin with right so I'm
assuming you can get out of bed right if
you're if you're crippled
psychologically and canot get out of bed
then it's a different conversation but
if you can get up and just like I really
just don't know what to do to get out of
this funk meditating twice a day for a
week I would say in the vast majority of
cases right 20 minutes a session twice a
day will make a difference it creates a
bit
of space in the
system and a little bit more
space it's like taking your thought
speed down to like 5x so that there's a
little bit more
space for you to be become aware of the
stories and the voice and so on but
honestly just slowing down which for me
meditating twice a day
does more than half the time I wonder if
the benefits that I get from it are just
not doing anything for 20 minutes I
could just like lay down on the floor
for 20 minutes but proving to myself
that I do not need to rush I have enough
time I have the luxury of being able to
take 2 20 minute breaks and then seeing
over the course of the week that oh I
actually get I actually get better
results with less stress when I do this
sometimes I think it's just sitting up
straight with good posture for 20
minutes I don't know the what the causal
factors are but I do think there's a
benefit there and I'm bringing up
because I do think that a regular
meditation practice has helped me to
accept some of the wobby saabi stuff and
where there's a point of diminishing
returns where there there's like
Improvement up to like 90% right and
then the last if you want to improve it
from 90% right to close to 100% right
first of all you're almost never going
to get to 100% because things change and
things deteriorate but let's just I'm
making up a number here but like let's
just say it takes you 5 hours or 50
hours to get 90% right it'll take
another 50 hours to do the last 10% it's
actually that's very different from my
experience of meditation all right tell
me and this is actually guess something
I've changed my mind on to talk at
dinner you become more Monkish well no I
think meditation can actually be
dangerous at certain levels so that's
that's something we have to explore but
the um for me my maybe it's how
meditating as well I get my system gets
very sensitive and very observant yeah
and so and I kind of also probably try
to use meditation a little bit as like a
mental exercise to improve like my
cognition my focus other things and that
Focus as well like I mean you know it
can sometimes or just the s to to the
system mhm you know talking about
downsides of meditation like there's you
know I know someone who like loved
blueberries and they got so sensitive to
their system they like can't eat
blueberries anymore from meditation
that's what they claim wow and there's
the pursuit of the janas which is really
big in San Francisco now like I got to
catch you up on a bunch of weird San
Francisco stuff all right so we'll get
caught up in the weird San Francisco
stuff I did just do an episode which
didn't get as much attention as I would
like it to get but I did an extended
episode with Dr
uh Willoughby Britain I'll put it in the
show notes on the hidden risks of
meditation actually oh cool and I'll
that and how they're addressed and how
they overlap with a lot of the risks of
psychedelics I believe that yeah
and which is not to say like don't do it
yeah Boogeyman in the closet like you're
going to do TM for 20 minutes and have
your brain implode like I'm not say do
of that is I think extremely low risk so
I'm thinking more like many hundreds of
hours like yeah then you get in trickier
territory I mean historically it's not
like everybody in the world was on
meditation apps like meditation was
reserved for pretty select group of
folks who had a lot of supervision 20
minutes so twice a day I find helpful
for example Mutual a friend of ours was
at my house recently and for whatever
reason I'm in an older house and there
are like 87 light switches there's so
many light switches it's so
unnecessary and there's one
panel with the switches that is like 10%
turned and he doesn't
have the fixation on details that I do
but he said to me he's like I am
astonished that you have not fixed that
because that must drive you insane he's
known me for a very long time and I was
like yeah you know this is like my daily
practice is to look at that that's cool
and be like you know what it's fine it's
fine
and there are many other bigger fish to
fry and that in a way kind of becomes my
practice it's in the kitchen I see it
every day and it's gotten to a point
where it doesn't bother me well and if
or when we have kids I think kids also
break up oh they're going to break
everything any Obsession you have with
keeping your house perfect I think goes
out the window yeah yeah it's going to
be game over I I'm almost done all right
what you got this last one is really
weird and then I have a funny one all
right so the weirdest thing I've been
exposed to recently Scott Alexander
actually wrote about it but have you
heard about this bacteria you put in
your mouth and eliminates cavities no
okay so we have bacteria in our mouth
it's a whole microbiome right I guess
there's a mutation on one of the
bacteria that they have essentially gmed
mhm a replacement okay so it's a the
bacteria I guess normally produces
lactic acid the lactic acid is what
breaks down your teeth creates cavities
okay in the ' 80s I guess a scientist
like discovered this in one of a
students mouth like it had two mutations
and they genetically modified it to add
a few more basically one instead of
lactic acid it'll produce alcohol okay
really trace him out so this is like not
even one drop but like it's it's not
like a a whiskey distill distillery in
your mouth yeah you're not getting drunk
from having this bacteria forget the
second one the third one was basically
something where it won't share this
mutation with other bacteria so it takes
out the thing that usually allows
bacteria to trade stuff and there
there's the fourth one I we're going to
have to look it up now cuz I forgot two
of the four things but you get a
one-time treatment of this so you
basically scrub your teeth a lot you put
in this new thing it takes over oh it
takes over from the old version of this
bacteria and that becomes the dominant
bacteria in your mouth huh it doesn't if
you you know kiss the friend or
something doesn't spread MH because they
would need to have their mouth kind of
the existing stuff removed first yeah
before the new thing could take their
parking spots are full parking spots are
full I guess the story is this guy tried
to get a FDA improved a scientist and he
created a company around it and the FDA
was like you need to test this on 100
children or 100 people who live more
than 100 people like under 30 who have
Dentures who live more than 5 miles from
a school or something like that so they
created this really messed up thing so
it's basically impossible weird some
hackers heard about this story first
they tried to clone it then they partner
with the guy to get like the formulation
and they're doing it like down in like
Central America someplace there's this
like libertarian what's the name of that
City that they they created oh it's the
crypto libertarian one it's like a
crypto libertarian thing in El Salvador
or something I'm blanking on the name so
it's called Lantern bioworks okay I have
no association not invest or anything um
I'm thinking about trying this it's a
little absurd okay Lantern bow work you
go down you get the treatment a onetime
thing I guess when they're bootstrapping
the company will be expens
like to make this a coup hundred oh
because this libertarian city has like
anything a consenting adult wants to do
for like a biot treatment you do as long
as you're informed of the risk so
they're going to like hopefully
commercialize it so they can make it a
couple hundred bucks yeah and then
finally they'll try to bring it back to
the US I guess there's different
regulations around
probiotics have you tried Z biotic I
have yeah I tried it this past I guess
maybe six months ago yeah I did not find
it this this to prevent hangovers is
this what we're talking about yeah it
helps metabolize the alcohol in stomach
yeah I did not see a huge difference
personally maybe I wasn't consuming
enough but yes I know what the product
is yeah so same idea so that's a GMO
biotic and I know people who swear by it
but for me I brought some just in case
this was going to be one of those
podcasts oh good good well look I'm
always up for a second ride at the rodeo
yeah there's a different regulation
around these probiotics so if they can
kind of get it reclassified as a
probiotic I think they can maybe bring
it into the us but how cool that maybe
in the future we won't have cavities
anymore cuz this will just be like
something we give to kids like as as
soon as they start to develop teeth and
then like how cool would that be yeah
wild so that's my weird thing and then
my funny thing this is also my what's in
my back post but it's a little device
USBC of course you never know when
you're going to need a party so it plugs
in so this is like a a disco ball that
plugs into the bottom of your iPhone
yeah USB see that's amazing you can get
adapters for lighting and different
stuff but uh you especially with the
holidays coming up New Year like just a
little pocket party yeah this is so fun
that is super fun amazing that's awesome
this is like $3 or something it's so
what would someone search to find that
it's on my post the what's in my back
post and I think this was like USB disco
light and literally you could you could
hold it you could cover the whole thing
in your hand it's very small but it does
look pretty much exactly like a dislay
with USBC one's out for you oh thank you
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas so great to hang man likewise
this has been a lot of fun always always
a great time we're going to head out
grab a bite to eat so we'll continue the
conversation anything else you'd like to
add before we wind to a close photomat p
h o t m t on all the socials but really
check out my blog M
MTT and we will add everything we talked
about to the show notes so folks can
peruse all of the things there's going
to be a lot at tim. Blog podcast and
search Mullen wig I should probably come
up with a more elegant way of directing
people to specific episodes but they
search you you've been on a bunch so
just look for the most recent episode
assuming that you're not listening to
this a few years hence and as always
till next time be just a little bit
Kinder than is necessary not just to
other people but to yourself remember
that Jack cornfield if your compassion
does not include yourself it is
incomplete and as always thanks for
tuning
in